it goes without saying that the SCP
Foundation archives are filled with some
terrifying monsters even the deadliest
creatures can in theory be defeated or
at least soundly avoided after all
they're just flesh and blood or in some
cases metal or concrete
but what if reality as you know it one
day just broke or worse you were
transported to a reality so frightening
and alien to our own that death seemed
like the only Escape but you couldn't
even give yourself that this brings us
to today's topic the terrifying
alternate reality of
scp-3001 the foundation is no stranger
to freaky alternate Dimensions but what
was experienced by joint lead researcher
Dr Robert Scranton at site 120 is a
truly unique nightmare come managed by
his wife Dr Anna Lang site 120 is a
facility largely designated for Research
into scps with dangerous reality warping
capabilities in order to mitigate future
containment breaches reality warpers are
among some of the more perplexing and
dangerous scps from the pocket Dimension
creating scp-106 to the SCP creating Dr
wondertainment and everything in between
Scranton and Lang's goal to further
study such entities was an admirable one
if a little over ambitious and on
January 2nd 2000 during the testing of a
new technology created by the
foundation's leading power couple
disaster finally struck
Scranton and Lang had already been the
brains behind one of the foundation's
most valuable tools in the fight against
reality bending scps the Scranton
reality anchors their follow-up the Lang
Scranton stabilizer or LSS likely would
have been an even more advanced variant
of their earlier invention and should
have been a huge success for the team
but things didn't turn out that way Dr
Scranton and several other researchers
were gathered in reality lab a
performing routine tests on the LSS
prototypes while other technicians ran
Diagnostics tests Scranton stood at the
control panel the blinking red light
above the console confirming that
everything was going according to plan
but as anyone who's Fallen victim to one
of the foundation's many anomalies will
tell you just because you've done
everything correctly doesn't mean you're
safe Scranton began operating the
machine not knowing that something was
rumbling up towards him from below
without warning a sudden unexpected
burst of seismic activity rocked the
entire base researchers grabbed on to
whatever was closest as the world shook
around them in this Panic Dr Scranton
clung to the LSS control panel as the
seismic blast fried the circuits and
kicked it into overdrive
there was a blast of magnificent
blinding light and when the rumbling
stopped Not only was the doctor gone he
had been erased from reality as we know
it the earthquake had caused a deadly
malfunction in the machine meant to
stabilize reality and instead tore a
rift in it dragging the unfortunate
doctor and the control panel into
Oblivion
his wife Dr Lang and the many
researchers who idolized him were
devastated by his unexpected demise at
the hand of what should have been his
crowning achievement the one silver
lining was that this reality ripping
event had almost definitely eliminated
the doctor quickly and painlessly as far
as the foundation and his loved ones
were concerned Scranton's death had been
immediate and complete a luxury afforded
to few Foundation employees who die
anomalous deaths but sadly that isn't
how Dr Scranton's story or the story of
scp-3001 ends no this is where it all
begins how do we know all this in the
hellish new place where Scranton had
been transported the control panel from
the LSS that he'd been clinging to for
dear life had been transported with him
and continued to record audio data from
this anomalous location not that Dr
Scranton realized it not at first anyway
as far as he knew he'd suddenly been
transported into a pitch black location
no sights no sounds no sound
true nothingness at first the doctor was
confused one second he was testing out
his new technology and the next he was
quite literally nowhere in spite of his
current situation the doctor was still
an intelligent and rational man he took
a moment to compose himself hoping that
in time his eyes would adjust to the new
Darkness around him but that moment
never came
the darkness remained perfectly absolute
much like the darkness in another
reality-defying SCP the deadly endless
staircase known as scp-087 the dark seem
thick almost like you could touch it the
doctor not wanting to give himself to
Despair and die in this impossible place
and with no other options seemingly
available began walking either he'd find
his way out or the foundation would find
him no need to panic it may have altered
the doctor's temperament if he knew that
the foundation already assumed he was
dead and that no search party was going
to come looking for him
still logic dictates that if a person
walks for long enough they're bound to
find something the problem Scranton was
about to face was that scp-3001 doesn't
run by any kind of conventional logic
he walked and walked and walked but he
didn't seem to get any nearer to or
farther from anything but how could he
even know after all in total darkness
there aren't any landmarks to assist in
navigation the doctor walked and paced
and screamed for days on end but he made
no progress he was alone in an empty
world he had no choice though so he kept
walking and walking and walking for 11
days during that time he felt his hunger
and thirst grow he was in terrible pain
from a mix of starvation and dehydration
but the release of death didn't seem to
come for him he was going to have to
learn the rules of this new place the
hard way and it grimly dawned on Dr
Scranton dying in this place might not
even be the worst possible outcome he
paced and repeated facts to himself
hoping to ground himself in the moment
and avoid the Panic that could so easily
set in name Robert Scranton age 39
birthday September 9 18 1961 favorite
color blue favorite song Living on a
Prayer wife
Anna little by little the words seem to
turn to nonsense in his mouth as the
terror grew just as he felt like he was
about to lose his mind he noticed
something a small Oasis in the endless
darkness of
scp-3001 the glowing red light on the
LSS control panel where had it come from
and how was it still recording the
doctor had no idea but he was grateful
for any kind of familiarity in this
strange Darkness around him perhaps the
LSS could be the key to saving him or at
least figuring out what on Earth was
going on here whatever the case there
was no denying that having the panel
here was better than nothing at least
when it was found if it was ever found
then people would know what had happened
to him as the days passed and he
continued to mysteriously survive Dr
Scranton deduced that one didn't need
food or water to survive continually in
scp-3001 the location had an anomalous
effect on its inhabitants
as the days passed and turned to weeks
of wandering in the darkness Dr Scranton
further deduced that he was no longer in
his home Dimension this was an entirely
separate pocket Dimension much like the
one possessed by scp-106 but featureless
a perfect self-contained void
now dimly illuminated by the red light
of the panel Dr Scranton explored
further into the void around him he
traveled for months on end the pain of
his deficiencies growing by the day but
found he was getting nowhere
All Things Considered he wasn't even
sure he was moving or whether reality
and darkness were swirling around him
like a thick liquid rather than walking
on a single flat surface he was moving
in all directions across a
three-dimensional plane the space-time
Continuum appeared to be entirely broken
here where movement is more defined by
the conscious intention to move than any
real geographical repositioning Dr
Scranton knew that this place broke
every single one of cajel's laws of
reality parameters and from his years
working with a plethora of reality
warpers in sight 120 he had a theory for
why this pocket Dimension was so strange
it had an extraordinarily weak Hume
field before we get back to Dr
Scranton's semi-living nightmare we need
a quick primer on Hume Theory and why
having a weak Hume field is such a
problem a Hume is a unit of measurement
for the strength and amount of reality
in a given location or being in an area
with an incredibly low Hume field
relative to our world such as scp-3001
Universe breaches and anomalous
incidents rise significantly at the time
is being trapped there
scp-3001 had the lowest number of Humes
in any recorded environment making it a
phenomenally anomalous Zone it was for
this reason that starvation and
dehydration never took hold of him
despite causing him great pain and the
worst by far was Yet to Come Dr Scranton
wasn't trapped in this dimension for
weeks or even months he was trapped in
the darkness for years and it took a
nightmarish toll on his body and mind
the small flashing red light on his LSS
control panel became his only friend and
as the years Drew on he would hold
entire conversations with his only
source of Illumination he knew that his
days were numbered if he didn't escape
the dimension within around three years
the Hume field would defuse further and
he would be left in a truly horrific
state but based on how little Headway
he'd made in the time he'd been there he
didn't feel optimistic he kept speaking
into the recorder if only to break the
silence and prevent him from going
completely insane but even that would
only hold it off for so long alone and
talking to himself endlessly in the
darkness Dr Scranton could feel his mind
slipping as the confines of the pocket
Dimension constricted and his body began
to change the low Hume field slowly
diffused his physical matter destroying
the physical Integrity of his body but
never being merciful enough to actually
let him die in this haunting audio logs
the doctor described his hands as
diffusing and thinning out like spider
webs over time there was less and less
of him and what was left wasn't entirely
human as Scranton's Hume level lowered
to equalize with that of scp-3001 the
lines between his body and the LSS
control console began to blur in a
Twisted marriage of warped flesh and
machine the Lang Scranton stabilizer was
anything but stable before his mind and
body became something else entirely the
doctor still had the presence of mind to
finally realize how he'd come to be in
this terrible place
the LSS had opened a wormhole known as a
Class C broken entry into a paradoxical
pocket Dimension between layers of
reality and taken him through it he'd
slipped through a crack in reality into
absolute darkness and now he was stuck
with a fate far worse than death how do
we know any of this much like the event
in the first place it's a total accident
testing Superior reality bending
technology almost six years after The
Disappearance caused the sudden Return
of the missing LSS to site-120's reality
labs
the only trace of Dr Scranton that it
brought back with it was the blood and
viscera that coded the console much to
the abject horror of his still grieving
wife Dr Anna Lang to this day Dr
Scranton formerly one of the
foundation's brightest Minds remains
trapped in the nightmare of
scp-3001 his current condition whether
the doctor is still alive after 20 years
of being warped by the low Hume field of
3001's dark and confines is still
unknown but for the doctor's own sake we
hope he's been dead for quite some time
because few things on Earth are as
horrifying as the alternative mobile
task force Edna 84 also known by the
code name and thus upon his Crucible is
on one of the strangest missions they've
ever been sent on they sit in a darkened
room beads of sweat trickling down their
brows the lights of computer monitors
shine upon their faces they're tackling
a monster that if it escapes will
literally devour all of creation it has
no fear it has has no remorse and if it
isn't kept contained by Edna 84 it may
escape and wreak havoc across the world
oh and did we mention it's trapped in a
Minecraft server you heard us right
scp-4335 is a Cognito hazardous
extra-dimensional being of pure Terror
trapped inside a procedurally generated
world in the immensely popular game
Minecraft you hear about a lot of
horrifying monsters being described as
lovecraftian but only this monster is
Minecraft in there's a lot that needs
explaining here and we intend to get to
all of it but let's start with how the
foundation keeps This truly exceptional
Beast contained the foundation first
discovered
scp-4335 back in 2010 shortly after the
Alpha version of Minecraft was released
because of the online nature of the game
it's proven to be impossible to contain
4335 externally seeing as it isn't
confined to any one physical location
shutting off the server 4335 is found in
is not an effective containment method
either as this just causes the entity to
Simply hop to a different server the
foundation's greatest fear is that 4335
will one day make the leap out of
Minecraft and cause chaos in our world
that's why it's imperative to draft
containment procedures for
scp-4335 within the game this led to the
creation of a containment site unlike
any other site M1 the first official
Foundation site made entirely out of
Minecraft blocks everyone who was
originally involved in the server has
been removed and amnestotized since then
Elite SCP Foundation containment
Specialists and Gamers have been
constructing the perfect prison for
scp-4335 site M1 is a large Stone
complex built into the side of a
mountain it has a number of key features
including a supply area filled with
materials vital for 4335's continued
contain attainment chests filled with
books that contain
scp-4335's containment procedures a few
animal farms for the purpose of breeding
and killing livestock for their meat the
entrance to a mine several chests
containing books specifically designed
for civilians to learn about 4335 if
they ever breach containment and enter
the server and of course the actual
containment chamber for
scp-4335 itself which is a little more
complicated
4335's containment chamber is built out
of several layers all made from iron
blocks the outermost cube is 75 by 75 by
75 blocks the inner cube is 55 by 55 by
55 blocks and the innermost cube is 25
by 25 by 25 blocks creating several
levels of Defense finally one layer
within all these others which contains
the anomaly proper is made from obsidian
blocks scp-43 35 is bound into the
center of the containment chamber with a
complex mechanism the outermost cube is
completely filled with water and several
dispensers capable of rapidly dispensing
large amounts of items in a short amount
of time lined the cube the cube also
contains several mob Farms which are
devices that constantly spawn enemies
into the chamber that drop loot when
they die the chamber is essentially
designed to funnel a constant flow of
items inwards to
scp-4335 there are even contingency
measures for if
scp-4335 manages to breach containment
if Escape is attempted blocks of TNT
detonate above the ceiling causing lava
to pour into the chamber at that point
MTF Edna 84 are dispatched into the
server to lure 4335 back into its
containment chamber to do this they fire
a mix of fire resistant potions and
ender pearls which have teleportation
capabilities interestingly there's one
more basic method of luring scp-4335
back into the obsidian Cube taunting and
insulting one of
scp-4335's many anomalous abilities is
being able to hear people through the
screen and being a proud creature it
often responds to insults by charging in
to directly Engage The insulter if
scp-4335 still manages to breach the
containment that has been set up for it
then they even expect that it will
likely soon hop into another server at
that point the goal will shift to
finding the monster and recontaining it
with containment procedures this complex
and extensive it shouldn't come as a
surprise that
scp-4335 rests firmly in the ketter
class what exactly is this anomalous
entity why does its containment hinge on
constantly providing it with items and
how did it end up in Mojang's popular
building and survival game in the first
place
scp-4335 in terms of physical dimensions
appears almost identical to the player
character with an all black skin it also
appears to be constantly shrouded in a
cloud of smoke particles and has long
black tendrils protruding from its back
in some respects 4335 has been compared
to two popular Creepypasta figures
Herobrine and the Slenderman but 4335 is
far stranger its physical body behaves
similarly to most assets native to the
game with a few peculiar anomalous
abilities we'll discuss soon handling
scp-4335 is an extremely delicate
process if command blocks creative mode
or server commands are ever enabled in a
server with
scp-4335 the server will instantly shut
down and
scp-4335 will move to a different server
scp-4335 also uses its tendrils to
destroy surrounding blocks before
consuming them with each successful
consumption
scp-4335 grows and when it reaches
sufficient size it hops to a different
server as you can see keeping
scp-4335 contained as an uphill battle
but luckily there are two factors on the
foundation side here the first is that
scp-4335 is immobilized while consuming
items and blocks limiting its ability to
actively Escape Foundation forces the
second factor is that
scp-4335 needs a rest period between
consuming blocks in order to grow
meaning if its consumption is constant
and continuous it isn't able to grow
these two factors have informed the
entirety of the foundation's containment
procedures around
scp-4335 it's locked into its chamber
and fed items and blocks constantly
effectively rooting it in place when
scp-4335 begins to grow the foundation
also found that the application of Ender
Pearls helps reduce it back to its
normal size however
scp-4335 does have a method of striking
back against its captors 4335 is a
virgin class multi-sensory Cognito
Hazard anyone viewing it without proper
training and protection may experience
distressing hallucinations
scp-4335 is also capable of telepathic
speech with people playing on its server
and as we alluded to earlier it can also
hear any noises you make while playing
weird is a term thrown around a lot when
it comes to scps considering it's pretty
much a requirement for the foundation to
take interest in you but in all
devouring Minecraft demon that can hear
you talking through your screen is
strange even by Foundation standards MTF
Edna 84 first discovered scp-4335 in the
single-player server of Minecraft user
leaking hard three team members Jason
yelsen Richard Duchamp and Shelia
Freemason covertly entered the game to
investigate and potentially apprehend
the creature when leaking Hart first
discovered their their presence on what
he thought was a private server he
quickly left a little creeped out by the
sudden intrusion thankfully the trio was
still able to locate
scp-4335 they discovered the creature
hiding inside a giant crater as though
it had impacted the Earth at
considerable speed Richard Duchamp who
is the leader of the team at the time
made the mistake of looking directly at
the entity in that moment he experienced
the full force of
scp-4335's Cognito hazardous effects he
hallucinated believing that his keyboard
was melting before his eyes in the
aftermath of this incident Duchamp was
taken off the case and Jason yelson was
promoted to head of the project things
were still going to get stranger Yeltsin
was able to open a dialogue with a
creature after containing it in a
chamber filled with lava it asked him
whether it had landed in the right
location meaning our world and Yeltsin
informed him that it somehow fallen into
the world world of Minecraft instead the
creature was at first confused and then
angry and resentful about its situation
it vowed to find its way into our world
somehow and obtain more sustenance a few
months after this The Entity managed to
breach containment and hop into another
server Yeltsin and two others once again
managed to track it down and recontain
it but this time two civilians also
inhabiting the server were exposed to
the anomalous effects of
scp-4335 they weren't heard but they did
appear strange and incoherent After
experiencing 4335's Cognito hazards the
foundation tracked them down in the
aftermath and gave them amnestic
treatment
4335 was contained shortly thereafter
once again Yeltsin came face to face
with his new phone eight months after
being captured 4335 granted Yeltsin
another interview from containment 4335
admitted that it almost respected
Yeltsin and the rest of the foundation
for figuring out how to capture and
contain it so quickly in exchange it
would give the foundation something
extremely valuable information first it
asked one question of yelson how does he
Define creation josephin replied uh
something that is built and brought into
this universe by a Sapient being using
other things from this universe 4335
agreed it went on to explain that it
came from a universe devoid of creation
a dark and unknowable place filled with
nothing but violent random chaos its
Dimension existed directly above ours
and it often looked down at us through a
dimensional window fascinated by all the
creation below it plotted and dreamed to
one day infiltrate our reality and
Yeltsin finally had the opportunity to
ask the magic question why though he
wasn't quite ready for the brutal
honesty of scp-43
335's reply I do not like to lie so I
will tell you now I wish to suck it dry
of the toys of whatever Force controls
your Universe destroy the light destroy
the Earth and Destroy Humanity it
reminded me of me a blubbering mass of
intelligence and order it sickens me in
ways I cannot comprehend I hope you
understand
scp-4335 was a connoisseur of creation
and it sought to devour all of it in
this moment Yeltsin realized what an
incredibly dangerous entity he was
dealing with the only mystery was why
this creature had somehow landed in
Minecraft instead of our world which
appeared to be the only thing that saved
us but Yeltsin didn't have time to think
4335 was about to Stage another daring
Escape
one of its tendrils reached out and
attacked yeltsin's player character in
that moment the real-life yelson began
to hallucinate and panic suddenly back
in the game a series of abnormally tall
slender black figures appeared and began
deconstructing the containment chamber
around
scp-4335 it had somehow summon new
minions into the game to assist in this
Containment Breach Jason yelson entered
Cognito Hazard quarantine following this
incident and was removed from the
project and he wasn't the only one
affected by this incident following the
first appearance of these long dark
figures players across the globe began
to experience them appearing in their
own game
the foundation managed to find a
solution they contacted Mojang and had
the creatures patched into the game
during the next update as a new
non-anomalous entity which seemed to
stop 4335 from being able to use them as
its own tools they're now known as the
Enderman and are beloved among fans for
being one of the creepier enemies to
this day containment efforts continue
for
scp-4335 but there's only one question
left why did The Entity fall into
Minecraft rather than our world the file
posits the most likely answer because
4335 defines creation as elements made
by Sapient beings in Minecraft the most
popular game in the world at the height
of 4335's power everything that exists
is the product of code made by humans
creation is truly abundant there as for
our world in
scp-4335's extra dimensional eyes there
is no no creation no intelligent design
no soothing piano soundtrack just
frightening chaotic Randomness which is
too unlike its own Dimension so even if
scp-4335 ever did arrive in our reality
we would likely be disappointed by how
little there is to eat oh here we go
again it's time for us to take another
crack at putting scp-682 six feet under
once and for all if you've been
following this channel for any amount of
time then there's one thing you know for
certain
scp-682 is harder to kill than pretty
much well anything we've made multiple
videos on the foundation's failed
attempts to finally terminate the Beast
and we've made a video with some of your
ideas on how to finally slay the monster
and considering you're watching this
video right now you can probably guess
how that went now it's time for one more
run at the Death Star and once again
it's with your ideas from comments and
Community post responses let's see if
any of them can help us finally put this
ill-tempered reptile to rest if we can't
well we're not blaming you but it's also
your fault let the community termination
attempts commence anas McBride suggested
ask the witch child
scp-239 also known as the witch child
this one of the most dangerous and
Powerful anomalies out there she's a
small girl with unparalleled reality
warping mental abilities so powerful
that her very brain waves alone can be
passively fatal however the problem is
her power is so potentially dangerous
that she's forever kept in a kind of
medically induced anomalous coma Dr Alto
Klatt thinks she's so dangerous he's
even campaigning to have her terminated
as a result the o5 council has forbidden
any cross-testing between 682 and 239
fearing the consequence of 682 gaining
239's powers and becoming a truly
Unstoppable threat capable causing an XK
Class end of the world scenario sierra
mean Alisha kazimi mushadi suggested
kill him with scp-734 this is an
interesting one
scp-734 also known as the baby is an
anomaly that causes a painful
degenerative disease that eventually
disintegrates the entire body and kills
the victim if they so much has come into
contact with the baby or its fluids
however based on Cross tests with other
similar touch it and die anomalies like
scp-409 the contagious Crystal we can
probably guess how exactly this would go
down in all likelihood the baby's
anomalous effects would infect and
Destroy large portions of
scp-682's body however at this point 682
would adapt to the threat and begin to
reverse it and heal even worse it's
likely that 682 would steal the ability
for a limited time and become deadly to
the touch Kaden Griffin suggested why
don't you use the dragon slayer to
terminate 682 it has proved itself many
times in fights with lsas
scp-5514 the dragon slayer is
essentially a giant fighting robot
designed to take down killer kaijus with
its plethora of state-of-the-art
anomalous weapons and defenses however
we'd still argue that while it could
definitely help in immobilizing 682
during a rampage it doesn't have much of
a chance of actually killing it let's
look at scp-001 the gate Guardian a
supernatural warrior with a blade hotter
than the sun capable of cleaving atoms
in half even he couldn't kill
scp-682 so robotic approximation with
only a fraction of the gate guardian's
power is probably not going to have any
real chance of killing 682 I'm a
chuckster 48 suggested make it bite its
tongue so hard that it just destroys
itself while we can certainly attest
from personal experience that this
really really hurts we worry that if
ever 682 bit its own tongue really hard
it'd just drive it into a state of
murderous rage though we do take a small
piece of satisfaction and knowing its
tongue would probably be in distress for
a few minutes afterwards it's unlikely
to wipe out the Beast once and for all
lazy Royce suggested how about we just
put scp-682 in 2317 cell
scp-2317 is an old wooden door that
functions as a portal into the domain of
the planet destroying monster known as
the Devourer of Worlds a being that many
believe is associated with the Scarlet
King and will inevitably escape and
cause an XK Class end of the world
scenario while you may be thinking
perhaps it'll kill 682 it's more likely
that it'll collaborate seeing as they
both want the same thing namely to kill
everyone if you let 682 in chances are
it'll come back through the door with
the Devourer right on its tail then it's
all of our problems guest one two three
one one six suggested drop him in Russia
so they can terminate him the foundation
has technically already tried this they
dropped 682 into scp-3930 a patch of
literal non-existence in Russia that
causes anything that goes inside of it
to cease to exist and afterwards he was
fine so yeah dropping him anywhere in
Russia is probably just going to get a
bunch of innocent Russian civilians
killed maisher said the foundation
shouldn't worry about how to kill him
but how to stop his ability to adapt I
would suggest typing
scp-682 no adaptability juice or
something like that into scp-294 and
then kill him by any means which should
kill him forever an interesting Theory
but what if he simply adapts to scp-682
no adaptability juice then we'd really
all be in trouble Mario tgp said give
him a Twitter account he'll be canceled
instantly for his spicy opinions
scp-682 would cancel Twitter itself for
not having opinions that are spicy
enough sorry Jack
scp-096 Still soar about losing the
battle we assume said let him fight the
Queen of England after all she's
Immortal too we definitely think it
would be interesting to see scp-682 go
head to head with the Queen of England
based on all the nighting she does we
know that she at least has a sword
though we don't know if that sword is as
powerful as the one wielded by the gate
Guardian but regardless of the outcome
the battle would definitely change
history every history book would simply
read s
cp682 punched the queen everything else
would just be a footnote Noah Cordero
said use
scp-2935 to kill the lizard as you can
see in the video he will die
scp-2935 also known as o death is
probably one of the scariest and
deadliest scps out there it killed an
entire alternate Dimension including an
alternate
scp-682 the problem is putting r682 into
2935's alternate reality could lead to
the destruction of our entire Dimension
why is that because if 682 was somehow
able to return to our world from the
world of 2935 it could bring the spirit
of death itself back with it and kill us
all in the process explorando con Beto
once suggested
scp-682 vs lady dimitrisk while Resident
Evil 8's lady Dimitris has certainly
captured all of our hearts we don't
think she'll be bringing home the W on
this one lady Dimitri has a powerful
adaptive ability of her own with a high
resistance to damage impressive
regenerative abilities and a number of
offensive capabilities from huge claws
to a powerful Dragon form however
considering she wasn't able to defeat
Ethan Winters she probably wouldn't be
able to defeat
scp-682 either however in her Dragon
form as cp682 May finally join the rest
of us in developing a crush or is that
being crushed anyway moving on Jonathan
pekines suggested just ask scp-343 on
how to destroy it or even better ask if
he could destroy it it's an idea so good
that the foundation actually tried it
and it went about as well as you can
expect when the SCP known as God entered
the containment chamber he couldn't even
see 682 in there as though the creature
was somehow totally invisible to him
when God eventually got bored and left
they told him that he was in there to
destroy 682 he simply replied he's not
one of mine deal with him yourself inter
interpret that how you will 12 Escobar
Blanca's Eddie Saul suggested they could
send him to area 37 for the Sisters to
experiment with
scp-1765 the sisters are a trio of
terrifyingly powerful reality warpers
that have taken over area 37 and spend
their days tormenting everyone inside
with their Twisted experiments using
them to try to terminate 682 leads to
similar problems with using the witch
child or the Devourer of Worlds if they
decide to team up rather than fighting
or the sisters take over 682 we'd all be
effectively doomed kiroya suggested with
the ants from scp-743 tear 682 apart the
foundation actually tried this getting
682 to consume chocolate from The
scp-743 Fountain incurring the wrath of
its flesh-eating ants however 682
developed an adaptation that gave it a
long anteater-like tongue that it then
used to consume the ants faster than
they could consume it and even worse the
chocolate seemed to enhance its
regenerative abilities even more for
several days afterwards ball 2222
suggested write the name in The Death
Note great idea we'll put it into
practice as soon as you can tell us as
cp682's real name it may come as a
surprise but its parents didn't actually
name it the hard to destroy reptile
Stephen Fury suggested I thought that
maybe we should put him in a giant
blender and then when he's in small
pieces put lava in the blender so it
will incinerate him then put nuclear
waste into the blender and repeat that
until there's no more left of him after
the cooking whisks last time we feel
obliged to include at least one attempt
to kill scp-682 with oversized kitchen
equipment in every video about him
however this attempt would probably go
about as well as the last one were
afraid extreme physical trauma by
conventional means like burning and
dismemberment has never been successful
in the past and the foundation is
extremely hesitant to use anything
Radioactive on the beast in case it
adapts and adds deadly radiation to its
own Arsenal Mr Master IQ suggested just
take away his plot armor you can pry
scp-682's plot armor from its cold dead
Claws and as we've already learned
making those claws cold and dead seems
next to Impossible moving on jc3
suggested hmm if anyone can't beat the
undying lizard why not omniman I mean he
did kill all the Guardians of the globe
of course he can kill scp-682 Omni man
from the comic and TV series Invincible
is undeniably a formidable opponent
given he's able to destroy superhero
teams cities and even planets however
one of the few enemies to give omniman a
genuine run for his money is a
Genetically Enhanced Kaiju known as Hail
Mary given that first 682 has taken on
being stronger than omniman like the
gate guardian and lived and second that
omniman has struggled with monsters
before chances are he probably couldn't
permanently kill this one either hey
Kenny javea suggests did Kill scp-053
then 682 will be sad and die wow now
that's cold-blooded however even if this
did work it's important for you to
remember that it's impossible to
actually kill scp-053 also known as the
child or the little girl part of her
anomalous abilities is that anyone who
attempts to kill her will themselves
immediately die during the process
normally due to a heart attack so this
method would result in a pile of dead
Foundation personnel and no progress
Jerry Zhang said mush peanut butter on
it this would definitely work if 682 had
some kind of severe peanut allergy after
all anaphylactic shock is no laughing
matter however in the far more likely
event that this will have no effect on
scp-682 you will likely just die with
your hands covered in peanut butter
Andrew Mills suggested my idea have
several Xenomorphs predators and Daleks
yes that's a doctor who reference takes
682 on once again in all likelihood this
would have no effect 682 has survived
blades and lasers the Primary Weapons of
the Predators and Daleks and spends the
majority of its life immersed in
powerful acid so the xenomorph would
hold no surprises for it sadly this
three-way team up would be no match for
682 and even if it did defeat him
whoever wins we um well you know how it
goes Mateo Huang suggested maybe just
destroy reality this this might be the
thing that finally kills scp-682 but
considering it's already survive being
thrown into pure nothingness in Russia
it may just result in it being one of
the only survivors of a full destruction
of reality we on the other hand would
all be killed though in a sense we
wouldn't have to deal with scp-682
anymore so maybe that's a type of
winning and finally blind honor
suggested would saitama be a good way to
eliminate it he is one punch man after
all of anyone we've covered in this
series saitama from one punch man would
probably be the most likely to kill
scp-682 especially if he was taking the
battle seriously after all he has killed
Planet destroying monsters before with
barely any effort the only real question
is whether he could be bothered to come
down to a foundation containment site
and fight it saitama hasn't been known
to be a very motivated guy but of course
like with anything there's the risk that
682 would survive and gain his powers
which would be bad awesome but bad it
was July of 2004 and Bill Murray was
enjoying the peak of an extremely
successful career
not only had the iconic actors starred
in some of the most beloved comedies of
the 20th century including Ghostbusters
and Groundhog Day he'd voiced the main
character of the recently released
live-action Garfield movie it'd been a
financial success but it was a critical
flop not that this bothered Bill he was
happy with the performance and the
paycheck
what he wouldn't be quite as happy about
was the horrifying encounter he was
about to have with scp-3166
on July 8th bill was enjoying a cold
drink on the porch of his luxurious
Beverly Hills Home the sky was beginning
to darken as the sun set in the west it
was a blissful evening his wife Jennifer
was inside watching TV nothing seemed
particularly out of the ordinary until
he noticed a quick flash of orange in
the distance it was almost too fast to
register this large orange-shaped
darting past the corner of his eye for a
second he entertained the thought that
it might have been an escaped Tiger but
it was gone too fast to really tell Bill
finished his drink and headed inside he
had enough for one night the next
morning he got up to read the paper and
found the Garfield movie getting
slaughtered by the critics one review
stated no one can accuse Garfield the
movie of infidelity to its source it
Faithfully conveys the banality of Jim
Davis's cartoon another called it a film
without energy and without spirit
put the paper down and ate his breakfast
a few blows to the ego were worth it for
the paydays that came with big budget
family films just then his wife came to
him with a strange question were you
walking around downstairs in the middle
of the night no he hadn't he'd been
sleeping like a baby why did she ask
well Jennifer said I heard some rustling
downstairs last night
sounded like something big
he hadn't heard anything though and told
her it was probably just Her Imagination
he put it out of his mind and continued
about his death he decided he would keep
his eyes peeled for that orange blur
again though Bill didn't see anything
peculiar the rest of the morning and
went to a local cafe for lunch he
ordered a coffee and a cream cheese
bagel then made a quick trip to the
bathroom while his food was prepared
when Bill returned to his table though
there was something strange
instead of a bagel there was a large
heaping of lasagna on the table what was
going on this Cafe didn't even serve
lasagna Bill knew something was terribly
wrong things only got stranger when bill
came home to find a small tuft of orange
Furs snagged on the frame of his front
door and it wasn't synthetic for her
like you'd see on plush toys or stuffed
animals no this was real animal fur
maybe someone was just goofing off or
trying to play some weird prank on him
but it didn't feel like it deep down
Bill Murray knew that he was in grave
danger whoever or whatever was behind
this
it wanted to hurt him that night his
worst fears were realized Bill's wife
had left town for the week and he was
headed to the kitchen in the middle of
the night for a glass of water when he
saw something a huge figure moving up
against the glass door leading to his
backyard the thing was huge nearly seven
feet tall with a bloated fur-covered
misshapen body that was pressed up
against the door its fur was bright
garish orange a cartoon or
strangest of all though was the sound it
was making
it sounded like it was purring Bill
backed away from the door and then ran
back to his room to hide the whole night
he sat cowering as he heard scratching
against the walls like something was
trying to get in he was terrified and
too scared to do anything even move
finally as morning broke the noises
seemed to stop Bill had to do something
he couldn't let this nightmare go on
another night what if things got worse
what if that thing managed to get inside
he called the local police and when they
arrived he explained the incredibly
strange situation as best he could he
told them he was being stalked by some
kind of huge cat or at least someone
dressed like a huge cat also there was
lasagna involved the officers
interviewing him could barely contain
their laughter as he told them his story
a giant orange cat perhaps one of them
theorized he angered some kind of
obsessive Garfield fan through his
involvement in the live-action movie
after all the original comic had been
running for years and had been extremely
popular who knows what kind of nut jobs
were obsessed with seeing only a
faithful adaptation of the source
material as the officers departed bill
was confident that they weren't taking
him seriously he couldn't rely on any of
them for protection thankfully from a
multi-decade movie career he had plenty
of disposable income and decided to hire
a private security team to protect him
while he looked into this mystery he had
two trained bodyguards positioned around
his home at all times for the next month
they were armed and given the cryptic
orders to fire on anything orange
meanwhile Bill began to Fall Down A
Garfield Rabbit Hole he felt strangely
compelled to research all the Garfield
media he could find as though the answer
to his terrifying situation was somehow
hidden between the lines Bill explored
the entire backlog of thousands of comic
strips he read the books and interviews
with Jim Davis he watched the cartoons
and straight to DVD animated movies
ironically for a guy who'd recently
portrayed the lasagna loving orange cat
Bill had never felt quite so immersed in
the character before
he found the strange Pathos in the
routine of Garfield and his friends one
particular comic really piqued his
interest though originally published in
October of 1989 the comic began with
Garfield being woken up by a strange
shell an almost Eerie sensation the
character observed aloud that he didn't
feel like he was in his own home he
explored his little home further trying
to find his owner John or his housemaid
and sometimes Nemesis Odie but found
nothing as Garfield remarked on feeling
alone a purple speechbox delivered the
Sinister message
you have no idea how alone you are
Garfield
he then finds that his home looks like
it's been abandoned for years
the for sale sign outside is practically
ancient
Garfield slowly comes to a horrifying
revelation
everyone really is gone
in his adventures and friends now exist
only in his imagination he's trapped in
a prison of his own creation trying to
Stave off his endless loneliness
in denial about the reality of his
situation the comic ended with a quote
directly from Jim Davis himself saying
an imagination is a powerful tool it
content memories of the past shade
perceptions of the present or paint a
future so vivid that it can entice or
terrify all depending upon how we
conduct ourselves today as he read those
words Bill Murray felt a chill down his
spine why had he wanted to get involved
in the Garfield movie in the first place
what have he gotten himself into before
he could slip any deeper into his own
mind Bill heard a faint choked scream
downstairs
he felt his breath catch in his throat
he was terrified but needed to see what
was happening
be carefully and quietly began to creep
down the stairs at the bottom he poked
his head around a corner and that's when
he saw a member of his security detail
lying dead on the floor his face was
Blue from asphyxiation his mouth was
stuffed with lasagna
it looked like he had been force-fed to
death
Bill wanted to scream but he couldn't or
maybe knew he shouldn't just then he
heard a soft meaty thumping noise coming
from the nearby living room he didn't
know why but he felt compelled to
approach as if by forces Beyond his
control he made his way to the living
room and when he'd got there he saw
where the noise was coming from Bill's
jaw dropped in pure horror there was the
other member of his security detail
lying limp and lifeless under a giant
orange figure it was a grotesquely huge
creature wearing what looked to be a
kind of crude Garfield outfit made of
sewn together cat palettes it's stank of
pasta and rotten meat in its giant Paw
It held the golden trophy which it was
using to pound the security guard's head
into mush while making quiet cat-like
purring noises the creature suddenly
stopped and looked up locking eyes with
Bill the fear of death came over him he
froze as the giant freakish Garfield
stepped over Donny's corpse and began to
come towards him bill turned and ran but
Garfield was gaining on him before he
could make it to the front door the
creature knocked him over he was laid
out on the ground looking up at it as it
reached into its own body cavity and
began to pull out handfuls of lasagna he
was about to shove a wad of the horrible
decaying pasta into Bill's mouth when
suddenly a ding Was Heard and the
creature stopped
looked up as if sniffing the air and
then suddenly turned and lumbered
towards the kitchen
Bill watched as the Garfield monster
entered the kitchen where somehow there
was a steaming hot fresh lasagna sitting
in the open oven the creature had sensed
the presence of external lasagna and
felt the compulsion to integrate it into
its body grabbing fistfuls and shoving
it into itself
just then a group of highly trained SCP
Foundation Personnel burst into the room
and subdued the creature
it had been an ambush the foundation had
been tipped off to the presence of the
creature by monitoring the local police
department dispatches and the report of
a seven foot tall comic book cat
terrorizing a Hollywood actor was
definitely worth looking into the
monster that had almost taken Bill
Murray's life was
scp-3166 a deadly pathophysical being
that tends to manifest around people
somehow involved in the Garfield
intellectual property it appears
whenever the public perception of
Garfield falls out of favor and because
Bill had starred in the critically pan
Garfield movie he was currently at the
very top of
scp-3166's Hit List
thankfully he managed to survive his
terrifying ordeal and was administered
amnestics by Foundation Personnel so
that he could return to his normal life
this frightening and mysterious creature
has been around since 1989 appearing
after the publication of The Haunting
Garfield comic that Bill had read that
very night
it appeared in the office of United
media who were the Publishers of the
Garfield comic strip at the time
and began wrecking Havoc since then the
creature's manifestation has been a
constant threat whenever Garfield loses
its popularity or audience as a result
the foundation has spent years as the
funding source behind all Garfield media
and even planting hypnotic mimetics into
the comic strips to ensure that there is
always a loyal fan base
the fur is indeed real organic cat fur
albeit an unnaturally orange color and
instead of organs the creature is filled
with lasagna worst of all though is that
testing has revealed that the meat in
the lasagna is genetically identical to
the Flesh of Garfield's Creator Jim
Davis how did this thing come into
existence perhaps it was Jim's sheer
force of imagination that dragged it
into being as he himself said an
imagination is a powerful tool all in
all it's lucky that Bill Murray was able
to survive his encounter and return to
his normal life well as normal as life
can be for Bill Murray and if you see
Bill Murray don't bother asking him
about scp-3166
the amnestics were quite effective and
just as he's fond of saying himself
no one will ever believe you Jay and
Michael were a pair of urban exploration
YouTubers looking for their big break
you might remember their video exploring
the dead mall on the outskirts of your
town or the supposedly haunted 1950s
insane asylum out in the sticks but you
certainly won't find these videos
anywhere online after the incident at
scp-823 all of their content was
scrubbed away from even the most
comprehensive internet archives why you
ask because these unfortunate Urban
explorers decided that their big break
would be exploring a certain abandoned
theme park and it would be one of the
last decisions they ever made Michael
and Jay had heard rumors about the theme
park its name was lost to time as was
the date of its opening and closing and
the reason it was even abandoned in the
first place even some of the most
hardcore Urban explorers didn't dare To
Tread there something about it a good
friend had once told Jay just did didn't
feel right sometimes if you dare to
venture into the forest near the theme
park at night you can still hear music
the Jolly piping tunes of rides and
Carnival stands still beckoning as if to
say we're still here come and play of
course none of this frightened Jay and
Michael they could already smell the
sponsorships from headlamp and compact
camera companies no amount of anxiety
would stop them from making their Doom
trip to the so-called Carnival of
Horrors it's a terrible shame if they'd
listen to the stories of this place
about how unnatural and evil it could be
they might still be alive today like all
the best Urban explorers they arrived at
the woods near the abandoned theme park
in the dead of night they ignored the
signs warning them about everything from
structural instability to dangerous wild
animals to asbestos nothing would keep
them out nothing they reached the
abandoned theme park not long after
though it was a mere shell of its former
self during the several decades of
Abandonment nature had reclaimed it the
ferris wheel was covered in overgrown
Ivy and the carnival stands were
blanketed with mold as the duo swept
through the grounds with their
flashlights and cameras they saw a faded
sign that bore the words Thriller
Chiller the Park's most popular roller
coaster they also took their time to
Marvel at the exceptionally creepy
looking Tunnel of Love the broken down
house of mirrors and a huge grinning
statue of the Park's former mascot happy
hippo this theme park was something out
of a nightmare which naturally made it
potential video gold but as the excited
Duo wandered further into the park they
couldn't help but notice the quiet tinny
carnival music music that seemed to be
drawing them closer Michael asked Jay if
he could hear the strange Impossible
music and felt a chill creep in when he
answered that he did could all the
stories be true they were lost in
thought but but their legs kept moving
they were getting closer to something
now they could feel a presence and was
that music getting louder and instant
later though another sound cut through
the silence bang bang it echoed out
through the still night air birds flew
from their perches in the trees Jay and
Michael both fell to the ground dead
their heads taken off by the 50 caliber
rounds of a highly trained mobile task
force sniper on the payroll of the SCP
Foundation their recording equipment
along with their bodies were taken and
destroyed any trace of them were
scrubbed from the internet it may seem a
little harsh but a bullet to the head is
much Kinder fade than what would have
awaited these two if they'd kept walking
that's because the carnival of Horrors
is no dark fairy tale the rumors are all
true and something really is waiting in
the dark that's why this abandoned theme
park is known to the SCP Foundation as
scp-823 a euclid-class anomaly with a
violent history what's even more
unnerving thing is that the researchers
studying 823 have repeatedly implored
the o5 council to increase the Park's
classification to ketir and allocate
more resources for containment only to
be denied but after you've heard about
the horrors that unfolded there and the
danger it poses you'll probably take the
researcher's side the park is divided
into two zones the yellow zone and the
Red Zone there are to be at least six
members of foundation Personnel present
in the yellow zone at all times to
ensure that no civilians wander in are
two Urban explorers earn themselves a
death sentence not just by wandering
into the yellow zone but passing
dangerously close to the Red Zone this
is the true epicenter of the Park's
dangerous anomalous activity it's a
place so hazardous that anyone entering
whether they're a civilian or a member
of foundation staff is to be executed at
a distance by sniper fire without
hesitation Once Upon a Time nobody knows
exactly when there was a theme park that
that seem no different to any other
eager children and thrill-seeking teens
arrived by the busload ready to stuff
their faces with cotton candy and corn
dogs and then reverse the process on a
vast array of roller coasters but even
then during these Good Times there was
something dark lurking behind the
cheerful facade little by little
everyone visitors and employees alike
started falling victim to strange and
horrific accidents around the park of
course when it comes to theme parks
accidents come with a territory but none
like this here are just a handful of the
horrific and mysterious deaths that
occurred while the park was opened so
strap in because just like a roller
coaster this isn't for the faint of
heart a pair of young lovebirds decided
they wanted to enjoy the Romance of the
tunnel of love the two sad in a swan
shaped boat as they were ferried through
darkened passageways anyone would assume
that they were having a great time but
at some point Terror terrible shrieks of
pain and fear began to echo through the
ride attendance confused and terrified
stopped the ride and found that the
screaming persisted just some stupid
teens playing a prank they figured and
started the ride again but when the swan
shaped boat finally exited the tunnel of
love the park employees were greeted to
a horrifying site the two teens dead
their bodies somehow fused together at
multiple points another unlucky customer
met a gruesome fate inside the house of
mirrors they entered but while inside
they were stalked by a mysterious
carnivorous humanoid entity known as
subject 79 the customer was pursued and
eventually caught by subject 79 and
brutally dismembered some parts of the
body were fused to the house of Mirror's
interior While others like the right arm
were never found the customer actually
survived their ordeal and whether that's
a happy ending is up to you but it
wasn't just the customers at the park
who were in danger a 23 year old Park
employee working a summer job collapsed
while entertaining children dressed as
the Park's cheerful mascot happy hippo
it wasn't uncommon for people to get
overheated and collapse in the heavy
suits on hot days but one thing was
different here he was screaming crying
and trying desperately to remove his
mask people rushed to help but nobody
could get the suit off and it was
declared dead soon after when he was
eventually cut out of the suit coroners
found that the employee had choked to
death his mouth trachea and lungs were
filled with a fibrous substance later
determined to be identical to the
stuffing of his costume an intense
roller coaster known as the Thriller
Chiller was a magnet for horrific
accidents which became more violent and
intense over time the first accident
seemed like a typical theme park tragedy
a safety harness failed dropping a rider
15 feet during an inverted Loop they
landed on the track below breaking their
neck and skull causing instant death
while this was a tragedy it wasn't
exactly anomalous but the next major
accident on the ride was an entirely
different story this time 15 people met
with disaster while riding the Thriller
Chiller roller coaster starting from the
front and moving back one car at a time
each group of riders was decapitated by
blunt force trauma a new pair of
decapitations appeared to happen at
every turn and loop on the ride forensic
scientists still have no idea how this
could have possibly occurred despite all
of these disasters the park was only
finally abandoned after a day known as
Bloody Sunday when the anomalous powers
of the location reached a 20-year Peak
it's believed that 231 people were
killed during the Carnage of that day
and another seven were horribly maimed
the SCP Foundation contained the
carnival of Horrors not long after but
the mysterious deaths didn't even end
there Foundation mobile task force row
71 also known as the origami tones were
summoned to assess containment
procedures and discover the source of
all the anomalous deaths they were
unsuccessful though and instead they
merely added to the list in
exceptionally horrifying ways One agent
was found dead surrounded by empty
grenades and bullet casings it appeared
he'd removed the explosive propellant
from all of his ballistics and consumed
it dying in the process another was
found with his jaw broken having
apparently pulled out and inhaled his
own teeth and dying of the resulting
internal damage the commander got the
worst fate of all so horrifying in fact
that we can't tell you the full details
all you need to know is that something
was shoved into his brain that really
didn't belong there the foundation
considered having the entire park
destroyed with a massive air strike
courtesy of the mobile Task Force new 7
AKA hammer down however the o5 council
denied this request on the basis that
the park was too close to populated land
they'd have no plausible cover story for
the bombing and they don't even really
know if blowing up the park would
prevent anomalous activity from
occurring the carnival of Horrors is
here to stay folks the foundation just
hopes to keep it from getting new
visitors so then back to why the
researchers want this place upgraded to
ketir after all these classifications
aren't about how dangerous an anomaly is
they're about how difficult and
complicated they are to contain but
here's the problem according to the
researchers the Red Zone where the
dangerous anomalous activity is at its
peak is inbound to one fixed position
its change position at least three times
already and even worse it appears to be
growing not seemingly so Euclid class
now is it after all you might not even
need to visit the carnival of Horrors to
be in grave danger if it keeps growing
then someday soon the carnival of
Horrors may be visiting you every
neighborhood has a house like it you can
probably picture it that old decrepit
building on the very end of the street
it was there when you moved in and it'll
still be there when you move out all
sorts of salicious rumors spread about
houses like this it's a drug lab it's a
hideout for fugitives it's haunted but
these are all just stories right some of
these houses contain real nightmares
though nightmares like
scp-136 there's a grain of Truth in
every story and even lies can reveal
certain facts about their tellers that's
why the SCP Foundation takes reports of
so-called neighborhood houses seriously
and performs regular checks on such
buildings to see if any of them are
actually the real deal children can have
wild imaginations but when children
living on the same street years apart
with no reason to have been in contact
with one another I'll start reporting an
eerily similar Apparition in that creepy
old house and when the stories go beyond
just getting freaked out and delve into
truly life-altering dramatic paralytic
Terror then the foundation really can
afford not to look into it one otherwise
quiet morning in a sleepy American town
a convoy of fumigation and asbestos
removal trucks pulled in surrounding
that creepy Old House at the End of the
Street residents were probably thinking
it's about time someone tore that old
death trap down as people in protective
suits spilled into the building these
were of course Foundation field agents
who would perform a routine sweep around
every room and fully catalog the place
it looked like a pretty typical
abandoned house peeling wallpaper Dusty
rotten furniture all the trash and
Rubble that seems to appear in the
absence of human life the full sweep
took little more than an hour but
towards the end of the observation
period agent Sims a field agent posted
in the former child's bedroom began
acting strangely he posed a question
over the team's shared radio frequency
hey can anyone else hear that laughter
confused the other people on the team
responded that no they could not hear
any laughter a few other agents came to
check on the room but they didn't hear
any laughter in there either even though
agent Sims appeared visibly
uncomfortable there was no identifiable
source for this discomfort the other
agents left him so they could continue
investigating the rest of the house
other than one agent's fraying nerves
there didn't appear to actually be
anything anomalous about the house then
agent Sims screamed and jumped out of
the Second Story window of the house
sailing down towards the ground and
fracturing his spine on impact what
could have made him do that we're
talking about an SCP Foundation field
agent here a highly trained individual
hand-picked by the foundation to observe
and track terrifying and potentially
deadly anomalies out in the field what
could he possibly have seen in that
decrepit old house that would lead him
to believe leaping to his death was a
preferable alternative to facing it this
was a question that the Foundation
absolutely had to get an answer to they
intensified their search on the child's
bedroom as the body of agent Sims was
carted away that's when they found the
object that they would later deem as
scp-136-1 a little rag doll made of old
cloth the kind of thing you could easily
imagine getting carted around by some
ragamuffin child at the turn of the last
century this was the only object of
interest in the entire room so it was
tagged bagged and taken back to the
nearest Foundation containment facility
for further testing they had no idea
what they were about to unleash when the
doll was first brought into its
containment chamber one particular
scientist on the research team Dr Myers
a headstrong young researcher freshly
farmed from a prestigious University
took a morbid interest in the doll
something about it even in the absence
of readily apparent anomalous effects
made her feel oddly uncomfortable the
dolls seemed to carry a vague Aura of
Doom was this what made agent Sims act
the way he had or was this only the
beginning a d-class was brought in for
the first wave of testing the
unfortunate former arsonist was forced
to Simply stand around in the room with
a doll and wait until something
interesting happened and for 20 minutes
no anomalous activity was reported then
the d-class began frantically looking
around the room like a frightened animal
Dr Myers who had been observing the test
radioed in and asked what was happening
it's this laughter this weird freaky
laughter like some crazy lady is in here
I can't see her though can any of you
see her can any of you hear that they
couldn't see or hear anything according
to all their monitors it was just a
lonely d-class standing around in an
otherwise empty room with nothing but a
ragdoll five minutes after the d-class
reported hearing the Eerie laughter he
collapsed to the ground shrieking like a
maniac and crawling away from something
he could not see he was emitting the
desperate screams of a man who truly
believed something was about to take his
life but nothing was there he backed
into the corner of the room jibbering
incoherently and scratching desperately
at the wall until his fingernails were
ripping off leaving bloody traces behind
in the end a pair of guards entered the
chamber and had to drag him out the
d-class had urinated in fear and seemed
to have temporarily lost the use of his
legs from sheer Panic he was out of
commission for several hours afterwards
breaking into on and off screaming fits
whenever someone approached him upon
reviewing the footage of the experiment
Dr Myers noticed something strange the
moment that the d-class had begun
screaming the doll had disappeared from
the room it only rematerialized in its
previous position when the d-class was
finally dragged from the room eventually
the d-class became Lucid enough to be
properly interviewed about his
experience he said that after first
hearing the laughter a sense of
overpowering dread had begun building
within him five minutes later that was
when the end city later dubbed
scp-136-2 first appeared the vision that
appeared to him could generously be
described as human but it was a little
too tall to really qualify the monster
appeared to be female but like a
freakish Carnival House of Mirror's
exaggeration of what one thinks of being
female long flowing hair large breasts
and a Barbie doll thin waist she looked
like the nightmarish doodle of a
hormonal teen boy come to life with a
face Twisted into a rictus grim
somewhere between arousal and Agony
showing way too many teeth the creature
was nude and posed provocatively but it
was anything but appealing the d-class
reported that just seeing it was the
most frightening experience of his life
and then it started moving it was slowly
floating through the air towards him
like a vengeful ghost that painful smile
getting wider as it drew closer to him
the d-class could only describe the
whole experience as feeling like death
itself was coming towards him when the
creature was finally looming over him as
he cowered in the corner it opened its
tooth line jaws and let out a long
piercing shriek before disappearing in
the following weeks the d-class was kept
for testing he experienced severe night
terrors every single night afterwards
all of them related to
scp-136 further Tess looked into the
doll itself but there didn't seem to be
anything anomalous about its
construction it appeared to be made from
the kind of plain non-anomalous
materials you'd expect from any doll of
this variety though occasionally the
exact materials would change even
between observers in addition to the
most common cloth variety Witnesses have
reported the doll being made of clay
wood and metal with 10 viewing the doll
as male with the rest all agreeing that
the doll is female the foundation
conducted a battery of tests on the doll
just to make sure that the results were
largely consistent across all subjects
over 25 subjects were tested on SCP 136
all reporting roughly the same results
laughter after 20 minutes of observation
a few minutes of silence and then
according to subject testimonials the
appearance of the same grinning naked
Apparition inducing a state of truly
Primal Terror in its victims
interestingly not all the subjects were
d-classes some were volunteering
scientists who were aware of the
potential effects but let their morbid
curiosity get the better of them
thinking they would be prepared to face
whatever terrifying vision would
manifest from the doll but in every case
they were reduced to the same screaming
traumatized wrecks but when a foundation
researcher named Dr Simon the 25th
subject of the scp-136 experiments
volunteered for testing things took an
even more horrifying turn during the
testing period Dr Simon had the unusual
experience of not actually seeing the
scp-136-2 entity after being told how
terrifying it was by my co-workers he
was a little disappointed that he didn't
get to share their fears later that day
he went to get himself a warm cup of
coffee from the science employee break
room his co-workers became concerned
when his coffee mug dropped to the
ground and shattered as Dr Simon pointed
into a nearby empty hallway and began
screaming he claimed that he could see
her floating down the hallway towards
him her face Twisted into that menacing
grin as none of the other scientists
could see what Simon was seeing they
surrounded him and attempted to calm him
assuming that he was perhaps the victim
of some kind of sudden psychotic break
but minutes later every scientist in the
break room collapsed and fell
unconscious not long after they all
began to wake up except Dr Simon he had
fallen into a coma and died while still
on life support three days later it was
the first report of scp-136 causing a
death since agent Sims unfortunate fall
Dr Myers immediately requested that a CP
p136 be reclassified from Euclid to
ketterclass so more resources could be
allotted for its containment
Administration denied any changes to the
containment procedures of scp-136
frustrating Dr Myers but little did she
know that it was because site
administration had ulterior motives for
scp-136 no matter who they were whether
they were the hardened killers of
d-class the trained soldiers of the
foundation field agent core or jaded
scientists who had seen any number of
Horrors each week as part of their
normal jobs
scp-136 had the unique ability to reduce
its victims to terrifying wrecks in a
move that feels decidedly more in line
with the chaos Insurgency site
administration had started using scp-136
to assist in enhanced interrogation with
detained people of Interest even the
toughest nuts to crack soon became very
talkative after the appearance of
scp-136-2 traumatized them for Life
essentially the admin administrators
were making a kind of deal with the
devil allowing scp-136 more free reign
in exchange for them Gathering valuable
Intel from these victims but as always
the problem with making deals with the
Devil is that the devil is always going
to collect his due in the end Dr Meyer's
warnings would continue to fall upon
deaf ears though even as the creature's
power seem to grow tests on d-class
continued with the entity traumatizing a
whole group at once during one of these
experiments however when Dr Myers
herself along with a few agents entered
the testing chamber to drag out their
twitching bodies they all fell
unconscious when Dr Myers woke back up
three of the d-classes had fallen into
Comas like Dr Simon and died shortly
after Dr Myers pleaded with the
administration to terminate the doll but
her requests were denied it was proving
to be too valuable in its various
interrogations and besides nobody was
sure if the doll could even be
terminated whenever it was damaged it
simply disappeared and reappeared within
a one meter radius the only thing that
hadn't been tried was full vaporization
which Dr Meyer superiors refused to sign
off on
scp-136 was here to stay unfortunately
the same could not be said for Dr Myers
herself after one more unfortunate
testing incident where d-class
disappeared entirely in what seemed to
be clear evidence of scp-136's Growing
Power Dr Myers implored site
Administration to reclassify the anomaly
and slate it for termination it was
getting more powerful more unstable and
more dangerous but rather than terminate
the anomalous Ragdoll in the end all
they did was remove Dr Myers from the
scp-136 case with her gone there was one
less thing for them to worry about as
they gave more and more victims to
scp-136 using its dark powers to torture
detained people of Interest into telling
them everything they wanted to know but
with the entity seeming to grow more
powerful with every victim it seems very
likely that Dr Meyer's worst fears will
come true and one day those controlling
the terrifying anomaly will find that
they're the ones hearing a strange evil
laughter coming from nowhere at all on a
cold October night in 2003 Shirley Yates
of Seattle Washington was just about to
get ready for bed when she heard a knock
at the door she approached the door and
asked the person on the other side to
identify themselves The Voice outside
responded immediately it was a Salesman
who just wanted a few moments of Mrs
Yates time this was odd for two reasons
first it was almost 10 o'clock at night
much later than as usual for
door-to-door salesman and second the
knock hadn't come from Mrs yates's front
door it was coming from the door to her
bathroom has your home ever been visited
by a door-to-door Salesman if you were
born in the last 40 years then your
answer to that question is probably no
in the age of online shopping the idea
of a salesperson going from house to
house Hocking vacuum cleaners or
encyclopedia sets Feels Like A Relic
from the past it's highly unlikely you'd
ever see one walking the streets
nowadays and equally unlikely that one
would knock on your front door however
if you live in Washington state you
might need to be wary of a certain
salesman who is still doing the rounds
scp-1879 also known as the indoor
salesman and the doorman is a phenomenon
that manifests randomly in homes
throughout Washington subjects will hear
persistent knocking from the interior
doors of their homes and the affected
door becomes classified as
scp-1879-1 the knocking doesn't stop
until the door is opened at which point
the subject will be greeted by
scp-1879-2 a Caucasian man of
indeterminate age standing around 170
centimeters tall the man will claim to
be a Salesman and immediately try to
pitch a bizarre product to the subject
whose home he's just invaded the SCP
Foundation was first alerted to the
existence of the indoor salesman when
they had intercepted a 9-1-1 call coming
from the home of Mrs Shirley Yates she
had opened the door to her bathroom in
an attempt to get the salesman to stop
knocking and once he was in her home he
refused to leave according to Yates he
kept disappearing in and out of random
doors in her house foundation field
agent Rogers was equipped with a
recording device and sent in to
investigate the case with several other
agents when he arrived at the home he
found Mrs Yates inconsolable
scp-1879-2 was still rapidly talking at
her and strangely enough the product he
was holding and trying to sell to her
was a Border Collie puppy as soon as
agent Rogers entered the room the man
shifted his attention away from Mrs
Yates and towards him he then started
trying to sell the puppy to agent Rogers
agent Rogers did not want to purchase
this puppy but he found that the man
spoke so quickly and urgently he
couldn't get a word in edgewise the man
was begging Rogers to take the puppy
practically shoving it in his face
saying that he didn't need any money and
that the only payment he needed would be
some of your time Rogers grew so annoyed
at being talked over and interrupted
that he ordered the other field agents
to apprehend the indoor salesman they
did so but as soon as the agents walked
him out of the front door of the house
he disappeared without a trace the
agents remained in the area to monitor
the situation
scp-1879-2 manifested again in Mrs
yates's home six hours later still
trying to trade the puppy for no money
just a little of her time 12 years to be
precise after hours and hours of being
worn down by this supernaturally pushy
salesman Yates relented and agreed to
take the puppy and immediately
disappeared the indoor salesman then
disappeared himself through the the
closet door before he could be
apprehended again at a loss for what to
do the agents administered Class A
amnestics to Mrs yates's family and left
the reason for her disappearance wasn't
fully known until 12 years later in 2015
when she reappeared in the same spot she
disappeared from having no concept of
how much time had passed the puppy
really had just cost her 12 years of her
life stories like that of Shirley Yates
have popped up all over the state in the
years since from Everett to Walla Walla
and everywhere in between due to the
random nature of
scp-1879 events and the way the indoor
salesman can disappear instantly in and
out of any door in the building the SCP
Foundation has been unable to capture
him the best they've been able to do is
Monitor 9-1-1 calls from across the
state listening for key words that might
indicate another
scp-1879 infestation when such an event
is reported the found Nation deploys
mobile task force Row 4 AKA shoes
salesman this task forces entire purpose
is to minimize the amount of harm the
indoor salesman is able to cause by
intercepting him before he can make a
sale this is a very important task as
evidenced by the story of Mrs Yates
since while the products this salesman
sells might be innocent he doesn't
accept payment in any normal currency
the price he asks for his products are
always bizarre and often deadly if all
someone loses is 12 years of their life
they could be considered to be getting
off easy in one instance the product
being sold was a single red rose in
exchange for the subject's heart once
the deal was sealed the subject dropped
dead on the spot with an autopsy
revealing that his heart and circulatory
system vanished from inside his body in
another the indoor salesman offered 220
bananas and told the subject to Simply
give him some sugar the subject agreed
and all candied Goods in the home
disappeared in a third the indoor
salesman was trying to sell a
thermonuclear Warhead the price of which
was the subject's soul the subject
accepted and at first nothing seemed to
have happened the foundation confiscated
the Warhead and placed it into
non-anomalous containment later that day
the subject went to listen to some music
only to find that two of her vinyl
records had gone missing Lady Soul and
Almighty Fire by world famous soul
singer Aretha Franklin so even though
he's incredibly invasive annoying and
his transactions can be deadly the
indoor salesman still maintains a sense
of humor the fact that the foundation
can't capture the indoor salesman means
that a lot of questions about him remain
unanswered the biggest by far is why he
does what he does in most
scp-1879 events the indoor salesman
seems frantic and desperate to make a
sale often he will refer to having
quotas and deadlines to meet which
implies some other unseen entity that he
has to answer to these questions remain
unanswered because all attempts to
interrogate the indoor salesmen have
been unsuccessful when he manifests in
the location it's impossible to get him
to stray from a sales pitch and he
disappears as soon as he successfully
sells his Wares however there was one
instance where after an
scp-1879 event took place Foundation
agents were there to witness a rare
interaction between the indoor salesman
and his mysterious employers agent
Rogers and the rest of the shoes
salesmen were called out to a home in
Spokane where rapid knocking had begun
to emanate from the bedroom door
equipped with recording devices Rogers
was able to record the voice of the
indoor salesman coming from inside the
bedroom in the recording the salesman
grumbled to himself about not being able
to meet his quota by tomorrow saying
that if he didn't he'd be stuck in this
world for the next Century he started
knocking again yelling through the door
that he knew they were home he kept
knocking until he was interrupted by the
sound of a phone ringing the indoor
salesman Was Heard picking it up and
Rogers managed to record the
conversation the person calling was
apparently the indoor salesman's boss
who was calling to complain about his
performance only one side of the
conversation was heard but evidently the
indoor salesman's boss wasn't too happy
about receiving two Aretha Franklin
albums as payment instead of an actual
human soul the indoor salesman
apologized for the joke then told his
boss it won't happen again please don't
head it I'll meet the quota this time I
swear he hung up grumbling to himself
again I better get to move up to at
least accounting this time I've paid my
dues and then some Rogers finally opened
the door to the apparent disappointment
of the indoor salesman who was hoping to
speak with the home's owner and was
quite annoyed at having another one of
his sales interrupted by MTF row 4.
Rogers tried to ask the indoor salesman
who he'd just been speaking to on the
phone but as usual the salesman started
talking talking over him now see here
let's think logically he said you know
I'm not going to tell you anything I
know you're not likely to buy what I'm
selling so let's just move on to greener
pastures I'm coming up close to a
deadline and I'm sure you're swamped
with making sure good people don't lose
their job so I'll just be on my way and
let you do that ciao the indoor salesman
tried to close the door but agent Rogers
blocked it with his arm he was tired of
this SCP giving him the runaround and he
was going to keep the indoor salesman
here if it was the last thing he did he
demanded The Entity stay and be
interviewed and other members of the
task force apprehended the salesman
making sure he couldn't leave the room
the indoor salesman now held in place by
several armed men seemed to finally
relent he told Rogers I'm busy so I'll
tell you what I'm gonna give you
something no money out of your pocket
and we'll call it even sound good Roger
is just wanting to get this whole thing
over with agreed to those terms three
seconds later every agent on the scene
was dead and the indoor salesman was
able to straighten his tie pick up his
briefcase and walk through the door to
the bathroom when the bodies of agent
Rogers and the rest of the MTF Row 4
were examined by Foundation scientists
the cause of death was found to be in
every case thousands of coins suddenly
appearing in not only their pockets but
also inside their stomachs lungs and
even under their skin later that day the
indoor salesman was reported at a home
in the same neighborhood he was seen
trying to sell The house's owner 80 year
old retiree Alan Johnson a Glock 18
pistol in exchange for his attention as
he had done so many times before the
indoor salesman disappeared through
another door before the foundation was
able to reach the scene and when the SCP
arrived they found Mr Johnson still
alive but now missing his prefrontal
cortex the part of the brain that
controls attention it's likely that
because of the nature of the entity
scp-1879 might be entirely in possible
to contain the foundation might never
find out anything more than what they
already know about the indoor salesman
the way he's able to manifest behind
closed doors or the reason he has to
keep filling quotas for an unseen boss
who apparently doesn't have a very good
sense of humor so if you're ever in
Washington state be careful who you open
your doors to especially if the knocking
you hear is coming from inside your
house there is a dangerous creature that
could be anywhere in the world hiding in
plain sight casually walking through
crowded streets filled with people a
monster that is nearly impossible to see
blending into its surroundings almost
perfectly Not Invisible but unnoticeable
almost completely undetectable but then
you spot a familiar outfit in a crowd
you now know where the creature is but
it goes both ways since the moment you
find it it knows where you are there is
now not a single place on the earth that
you could hide where it would and find
you and it won't ever stop looking do
the staff at the foundation this
creature is known as
scp-4885 but you and I know him by a
different name you may have seen this
face hundreds of times or stared for
hours at a page trying to catch a
glimpse of him to us he's Waldo while
this might feel like a very long-winded
and silly joke maybe even a prank that
has been inserted into the SCP archives
it is anything but if you grew up
anytime after the late 1980s then you
will likely be familiar with the where's
Waldo books but for the uninitiated
there are a series of puzzle books
created by illustrator Martin Hanford
each book in the where's Waldo line
contains multiple double page spreads of
colorful crowded scenes the goal is for
readers to spot the ever elusive titular
character Waldo who is hidden among the
mass of other characters Waldo himself
is easily recognized thanks to a design
that has become truly iconic over the
years he is always depicted as wearing a
red and white striped shirt with a
bobble hat and matching colors waldoaso
Sports jeans circular rimmed glasses and
sometimes a wooden walking stick so with
that important context out of the way up
front what exactly is
scp-4885 is the character from these
children's books somehow brought to life
has the character of Waldo always been a
malicious malevolent entity too powerful
to be contained within his own books
well not exactly
scp-4885 only seems to resemble the
famous children's book character whether
or not he is the living manifestation of
Waldo in the real world is both unclear
and Up For Debate examining its outward
appearance
scp-4885 does share the humanoid shape
and looks to be wearing the same
recognizable clothing of Waldo there are
however two notable bodily
dissimilarities between the Waldo on the
page and the physical form of
scp-4885 for one this Waldo appears to
be much paler to the one found in the
book series more noticeably however is
the fact despite wearing the same
circular glasses
scp-4885 seems to have no eyes should a
person learn of
scp-4885's current location Waldo will
simultaneously gain an awareness of this
person learning instantly of their
victim's location
scp-4885 will Traverse any space
necessary tracking their target down to
anywhere they might be in the world the
creatures displayed a number of space
altering abilities including
teleportation
scp-4885 can also alter the state of his
own matter allowing Waldo to phase
through solid surfaces no obstacle can
stop his Advance not walls not buildings
not even his victim's own body when
scp-4885 finally reaches the person who
has learned of his location Waldo will
then proceed to murder them in an
exceptionally excruciating manner using
his matter changing abilities he will
teleport or phase himself inside his
victim pulling himself through their
body and destroying their
after causing catastrophic bodily damage
scp-4885 will then wrench their victim's
jaw open unhinging it with enough Force
to climb his way out of their mouth
leave ing them dead their body
completely mangled however this isn't
even the final stage of Waldo's attack
there is a strange byproduct left after
a fatal encounter with
scp-4885 a yellow liquid that is
produced as Waldo exits his victim's
body when this substance comes into
contact with the deceased person's skin
it triggers a bizarre change the liquid
will cause their bodies to change after
death their skin becoming covered in
symbols on closer inspection it becomes
clear that these symbols are
illustrations exactly like the ones
found in the pages of where's Waldo
these corpses referred to by the
foundation as instances of
scp-4885-1 will then start to act in a
similar manner to
scp-4885 and anyone who sees one or
learns of its location will cause Waldo
to come looking for them the where's
Waldo scenes left on a deceased victim's
skin cannot be washed off or other
otherwise removed and the only way to
undo an instance of
scp-4885-1 is to skin an infected body
after death however this creates a whole
new problem if someone was to attempt
this in doing so they would know the
location of one of Waldo's victims this
knowledge would mean that whomever was
trying to skin one of these bodies would
themselves become Waldo's next Target
and would likely end up just another
instance of scp-4885-1
in other words it would be an exercise
in futility naturally the nature of
visibilities and attack patterns make it
difficult for the SCP Foundation to
contain Waldo
scp-4885 cannot be harmed through the
use of firearms or other common
Conventional Weapons at the foundation's
disposal you might be forgiven for
thinking that making a handful of people
aware of where to find Waldo at the same
time would be a viable solution after
all he cannot be in multiple places at
once so perhaps he'd be unable to kill
these individuals simultaneously however
scp-4885 has shown to be able to cope
with this approach dispatching his
victims one at a time transforming each
in turn into where's Waldo printed
corpses before continuing to the next
would-be victim if the victim is nearby
Waldo will force himself into their
mouth passing through their body and
destroying bones organs and even the
spinal column when victim is further
away Waldo will phase through the
nearest wall and attack them teleporting
into his Target and then climbing out of
their mouth Waldo's location or that of
his victim's bodies are considered info
hazards simply being aware of this
information will cause
scp-4885 to activate as a result of this
the staff at the SCP Foundation are not
even sure that Waldo is actually
contained at all in theory
scp-4885 is being held at an undisclosed
Foundation site within a non-designed
containment chamber since even a number
on the door would tip off what's inside
triggering while those abilities but
here's The Clincher because nobody can
know for sure where Waldo is without him
coming for them nobody at the foundation
actually knows where he's being
contained if he's even retained at all
it is worth noting that if someone
receives a vague non-specific
description of Waldo's whereabouts that
he will make no attempt to seek them out
if he is contained and if he was to ever
breach containment then the SCP
Foundation has an entire set of
procedures in place to ensure that no
one ever finds Waldo first 36
containment Chambers identical to the
one
scp-4885 is supposedly held in are
connected to a self-driving vehicle an
Expendable d-class Personnel member is
placed into the vehicle and a random
number generator will select a number
from 1 to 36. the self-driving vehicle
will then arrive at the containment
chamber chosen at random and the d-class
placed inside within each chamber are
digital monitors and once the d-class is
inside the chamber all of these monitors
will display the current location of
scp-4885 the foundation has kept a GPS
tracking device implanted within Waldo
but this information is normally kept
secret to avoid any
reaches the d-class essentially acts as
bait for Waldo forcibly given the
knowledge of his location so that
scp-4885 will consider them a Target as
part of the next phase of containment
Foundation staff Will Wait giving Waldo
enough time to arrive in the containment
chamber and dispatch the d-class within
after this all of the 36 containment
Chambers are transported to random
Foundation sites in disguised trucks so
that no one is sure where
scp-4885 ends up every time
scp-4885 breaches containment the entire
procedure has to be repeated the
foundation first encountered
scp-4885 a number of years ago inside a
small wooden house the exact location of
which has since been expunged from all
the SCP foundation's records while on
assignment to secure an entirely
different anomaly the foundation's
mobile task force chai 19 also codenamed
unrelenting punishment were the first to
discover while
the three-person unit consisted of
foundation operatives named Amelia
Merrick James Klein and Kurt Stahl the
trio cautiously entered the wooden house
where they were meant to investigate
reports of an anomalous inanimate object
a pair of black spectacles according to
initial intelligence gathered by the SCP
Foundation these glasses were capable of
killing anyone that tried to wear them
leaving their body covered in pictures
like those found in the children's book
sounds familiar doesn't it it is unknown
if these black spectacles are the same
eyewear worn by
scp-4885 but it doesn't seem like too
far of a leap to assume that this may
well have been the case searching the
ground floor of the team had found no
sign of the object they had been sent to
recover as Amelia Kurt and James made
their way upstairs something began
making scraping sounds beneath them but
none of them noticed in an abandoned
bedroom on the upstairs floor of the
house Kurt spotted a drawing on the wall
which looked to have been made using
crayon he took a photo of the
illustration and this image is still
kept in the foundation's database it
appears to be a child's drawing
depicting
scp-4885 wearing his signature striped
shirt and hat with empty vacant eyes
next to it was scrawled one simple
phrase Waldo found mommy continuing
their way through the house the team
located the glasses they were looking
for in an upstairs bathroom however as
James bagged up the spectacles ready for
transport back to the foundation Kurt
spotted another inscription on the
nearby wall one that the team were
certain hadn't been there when they had
arrived James stepped in to translate
using the foundation standard issue
translation device the phrase on the
wall red the basement the corpses from a
child's book are in the basement he is
there too for and we're sure that you
can already guess what happened after
that immediately after reading these
words James began to groan and clutched
at his stomach showing signs of extreme
pain before Emilia or occurred had any
chance to figure out what was happening
to their squad mate fingers began
protruding from James's mouth they
gripped his jaw and pulled it apart with
enough Force to send his Jawbone flying
across the room
scp-4885 climbed its way out of James's
body and Amelia and Kurt both opened
fire on the creature Waldo did not react
seemingly unfazed by the gunfire and
sustaining no damage as he approached
Amelia who would be his next victim
shoving his fingers into her throat
Waldo wrenched apart Amelia's jaw
breaking it before he clawed his way
into her mouth as he watched in Horror
kurd made a panicked call for help to
the foundation but it was too late Waldo
had already dispatched both James and
Amelia and now Kurt was about to pay the
same terrible Price ever since this
incident the foundation believes that
they have
p4885 contained when his file was
created the researchers created an
automated algorithm designed to wipe
away any mention of
scp-4885's current location or the house
he was discovered in from Foundation
records with scp-4885 now assumed to be
contained that only leaves one question
the same burning inquiry that's been
plaguing man for decades where's Waldo
in this case maybe it's safer if you
didn't no growing up in a small Virginia
Town near the mountains right on the
border of West Virginia Zane heard all
kinds of stories from his grandmother
Tales of mountain lions who could
transform into ghostly women the talipo
a fluffy rodent-like creature on an
endless quest to get its tail back from
the hunter who took it the Mothman that
appeared with glowing red eyes to warn
of impending tragedy most of all she
warned him about the deer sometimes she
used to say when you're out in the woods
late at night you'll see a deer acting a
little bit funny maybe it's making
strange sounds maybe it's standing up
like a man maybe it's staring at you
from the shadows and won't look away if
you ever see one of these deer promise
me you'll get away from it as fast as
possible don't look at it don't talk to
it just get far far away he promised her
every time but as he got older he
started to forget his grandma's stories
letting them fade away with memories of
the Easter Bunny and Santa Claus he
didn't think about the stories again
until he was older a junior in college
and embarking on a camping trip with his
roommate Josh they were both staying
with Zayn's family for the summer and
had been enjoying the sunshine and fresh
air they'd gone hiking picked
blackberries and gone fishing to their
hearts content after a while they got
sick of sleeping in the cramped house
and decided to have a proper camping
trip out in the mountains campsites were
crowded this time of year but Zang knew
a spot just isolated enough that they
could kick back enjoy nature and relax
in peace they packed their supplies and
headed out into the forest for a weekend
they would never forget by Nightfall
Zane and Josh had pitched their tents
built a fire and were starting to make
some dinner they roasted hot dogs and
heated cans of beans over the fire and
decided to start telling some classic
scary stories sitting by the crackling
fire listening to the rustling leaves
snapping twigs and the chittering of
animals all around Zayn couldn't help
but remember remember the stories he had
almost forgotten all the strange
inexplicable things that came out after
the sun went down and the forest went
quiet he thought he could hear the
footsteps of something walking by their
campsite circling them but it was
probably just his imagination as Josh
told stories about babysitters stalked
by Killers and drivers picking up
ghostly hitchhikers Zane was thinking
about the deer he shuddered but shook it
off and after some more stories and a
few too many s'mores the two friends
decided to get some sleep after several
hours Zane woke to the sound of Josh
unzipping his tent he sat up ready to
yell at his friend for waking him up but
the sight of Josh's pale frightened face
stopped him there's something here was
all Josh could say his hands Zane
noticed were shaking hey man it's it's
okay let's check it out Zane patted Josh
on the shoulder he was pretty sure his
friend just wasn't used to camping in
actual nature but reach for his hunting
knife just in case
he grabbed a flashlight and switched it
on following Josh out into the darkness
he swept the beam across the clearing
and it illuminated a pair of orange eyes
staring directly at him from behind a
nearby tree what the he approached the
shape trying to get a clear look at it
as it became more illuminated his
stomach dropped it was a deer but
something was wrong with it its mouth
was wide open its jaw working up and
down like it was trying to make a sound
but nothing came out but that wasn't the
worst part as the flashlight beam
illuminated the animal's body Zane
realized that somehow its head was on
backwards what the Josh appeared behind
him gasping shh Zayn shushed him
intensely he suddenly remembered his
grandmother's warnings you know what I
don't feel so great I think we should go
back to the car and head to my place he
gave Josh a look shaking his head as if
to say don't say another word by the
glow of their flashlights the two packed
up their campsite all under the Gaze of
the misshapen deer they drove home in
silence Josh only speaking once to ask
what was that thing Zayn shook his head
I don't know but it wasn't a deer they
crept back into the house and went to
bed they knew they would never speak of
tonight ever again as Zane began to
Drift Off to Sleep his last conscious
thought was to glance out the window
there in the yard not five feet away was
a deer watching he didn't know it but
that night Zane encountered an instance
of
scp-6448
scp-6448 is an anomalous species of
creatures that appear to belong to the
server Day family nicknamed the not deer
they are highly Intel and can be
distinguished from ordinary deer by
unusual behavior and physical
deformities some of these have included
legs that bend backwards the eyes of an
animal other than deer forward-facing
eyes jerky movements lack of fear
towards humans and walking on two hind
legs most notably and most frightening
scp-6448 instances will watch and stalk
humans for a duration of hours or even
days it will follow humans home and
steal items from their domains including
weapons food and other personal items
they're most frequently found in the
Deep Woods at night when a person is
completely alone if someone encounters
an instance of
scp-6448 if they acknowledge any of the
creature's anomalous traits it will
attack in order to limit the loss of
life and ensure that the SCP Foundation
employs exercise the utmost caution when
dealing with
scp-6448 the cryptozoology division
issued the following guidelines if you
notice a deer that seems off look away
and ignore it if it knows that you've
noticed it it's too late if you hear
your name whistling or something else in
the woods calling for you don't
acknowledge it never acknowledge it
exists don't respond don't go looking
for it don't call back to it if you're
walking at night and you feel something
breathing on your neck or Whispering
behind you the key to your safety is
pretending that everything is normal
your survival is dependent on your
ignorance whatever
scp-6448 is they appear to be
intelligent enough to understand when
they are being studied and they don't
seem to like it very much on January 11
1994 a group of three
scp-6448 instances broke into site-41 in
North Carolina using a tunnel they had
carved over a long period of time at the
time there was an instant in containment
but in all of the chaos of the breach
the specimen was lost every time an
instance was captured and contained near
scp-6448's habitat he would later Escape
via similar tunnels
scp-6448 was officially classified by
the SCP Foundation in 1980 but those
from the Appalachian region have known
about these strange creatures since at
least
1947. from folk tales and campfire
stories to Second Hand and even
first-hand encounters the locals are
aware of the not deer's existence and
are largely familiar with the
precautions necessary to avoid them
though many of the civilians that
encounter
scp-6448 avoid notifying the authorities
there have been several recorded 9-1-1
calls involving the not deer since 2000.
the following is a log of those calls
February 1st 2000 victim age 41 female
dialed Emergency Services after hearing
their name being called from the woods
near their home the victim recounts the
vocalization being likened to a scream
and a voice that they do not recognize
and requested assistance in locating the
source emergency Personnel requested the
subject Place their phone on the floor
outside the home to listen for the
alleged sounds after two minutes a
vocalization was heard that was calling
to the subject by name emanating from
the nearby Forest the subject was
instructed to investigate the
disturbance themselves and keep Services
updated on the situation the victim then
began to walk into the Woodland getting
about 50 meters into the underbrush
before inexplicably stopping they claim
there to be a noticeably large deer
standing in the way of the path she
begins to walk closer though States it
does not move subject diverts From the
Path and begins walking in a different
direction after 30 minutes no source of
the voice is determined the caller
returns to the residence June 13 2002
victim age 28 male calls 9-1-1 regarding
a home break-in the caller notes
numerous items to be missing from their
residence and requests and investigation
operators dispatched two investigators
to visit the home and and pertain a
potential perpetrator the pair note that
based on earlier CCTV images all Cutlery
sharp objects Firearms light bulbs and a
single copy of the novel The Day After
Roswell are missing also noted is that
there is a complete lack of any
fingerprints at the scene with no doors
or Windows having been broken into
analysis of the home CCTV footage
revealed there to be a two-hour period
of missing film with the exception of a
single frame containing a service Nippon
on its hind legs reaching towards the
camera its frontal Hooves have been
warped to resemble fingers no footage of
the entity exiting the home was
discovered November 19 2005 a cattle
farmer age 54 male reported to local
authorities the sudden disappear of over
30 percent of his largest herd response
teams surged the nearby area for four
hours though found no trace of his
cattle the victim was recommended to set
up trail cameras and note any unusual
activity overnight at 1 11 am two
scp-6448 are seen walking through the
field before fleeing one places an
object into the ground later discovered
to be a single Fork a week after this
discovery 200 discarded bovine Hooves
appear at the location March 4th 2009
victim age unknown gender unknown dials
9-1-1 to request assistance from Animal
Services the victim is standing within a
forest in front of a service elephus
which is violently contorting the victim
attempts to State you better get a vet
or something I don't think it's well
before piercing Screech is heard and the
line Falls silent recovered footage
depicts the aforementioned animal
squirming seemingly in pain a vicious
churning is audible as a black mass
erupts out of the instance and the video
turns to static October 11 2012 victim
age 23 male is a junior Wildlife officer
at the Cherokee National Forest
Tennessee they radio their supervisor in
the early morning regarding a herd of
audacolius virginius within the reserve
supposedly there is a single animal that
upon first glance appears average though
possesses Divergent attributes including
backwards joints enlarged abdomen and
forward-facing Eyes Upon stating this a
distant whistle is Audible and the
victim stumbles slightly they begin to
say what the did it just whistle at me
before the sound of hooves rapidly
getting closer is heard notably the hoof
steps did not sound to be in the
traditional Gallop of a servid October
12 2012 the former victim supervisor
calls authorities following the victim's
absence from The Reserve Night Shift
following this the radio begins to
crackle the victim's voice can be heard
on the other end and requests the
supervisor's attention he calls
regarding a herd of odacolius virginius
within the reserve they claim there is a
single animal that upon first glance
appears average though possesses
Divergent attributes including backwards
joints enlarged abdomen and
forward-facing eyes suspecting the
creature to be a rare genetic
malformation the victim requests their
supervisor to come to the location the
supervisor questions the victim about
what happened the night previous there
is no reply upon the supervisors and law
enforcement's arrival at the site a herd
of approximately 80 oticolios virginius
was present a single entity is in the
field Center and appears to be standing
separate from the rest of the group it
flees the scene upon realizing the law
enforcement's presence where it formally
stood lay a standard two-way radio April
8 2016. victim age 35 female dials 9-1-1
using a satellite phone distressed they
State they are in redactive County wood
and are being followed she claims that
despite seeing no one for the duration
of her hike she quote feels as if she's
being watched and has heard someone
walking behind her at various points in
the trip the victim is unable to give an
adequate description of their location
but knows the route to return to her
residence operators request the victim
to return to a point wherein she can
provide a sufficient Geographic
description of her position the victim
remains on the line for the duration of
a hike back to a readily used portion of
the Wilderness Trail along the journey
various unnatural sounds can be heard
these include footsteps Rock slides
coughing whispering and whistling
nearing the main trail all Woodland
noises such as birds and winds see
suddenly and the victims State she can
see a malformed deer carcass coated in a
thick layer of black slime at this time
human screams can be heard in the
distance operators request the victim
continue and ignore the other stimuli
agents embedded in local law enforcement
suspecting as
6448 involved notify gamma 4 to the
situation 20 minutes later the victim
returns to the main trail gamma 4 now
operating the 9-1-1 call informs the
victim not to respond to any further
unusual activity and greatly outlines
service protocol for the duration of the
victim's journey to her home two sets of
breathing are audible the victim
successfully returns to a residence and
shuts the door behind her now out of
sight from
scp-6448 Agents inquire of the victim's
address and the victim promptly complies
operatives instruct the victim to have
possession of all firearms and weapons
on the premises and to barricade herself
inside a safe space with one exit point
the victim swiftly begins grabbing all
available weapons and throwing them
inside a wardrobe it is at this time
there's a knock on the front door the
victim does not respond and continues to
hoard sharp objects from kitchen drawers
the knocking becomes more violent as the
handle is jostled and is shaken
incessantly a voice on the other side
repeats the phrase hello it is me hello
let me in in a calm manner as the door
begins to shake the victim retreats to
her wardrobe armed with a small firearm
upon sealing herself in the space the
knocking ceases and footsteps can be
heard becoming further away the sound of
Galloping is audible as the front door
caves in hoof steps can now be heard
inside the home The Entity continues to
repeat hello it is me hello let me in as
it searches the small building a bright
light flashes overhead seemingly
circling the house eventually The Entity
enters the victim's bedroom through a
small slit in the wardrobe door the
victim can see a service canadensis
standing on its hind legs and surveying
the room its movements are crooked and
stiff seeming to struggle to stand in a
bipedal fashion it slouches down to a
quadrupedal Crouch similar to The Stance
of an arachnid it inhales heavily and
its head locks on The View of the
Wardrobe it is noted as possessing human
eyes it scampers towards the subject and
opens the door a single gunshot is heard
responders found no trace of either
scp-6448 or the victim containment of
scp-6448 is focused on the investigation
of any deer exhibiting anomalous trades
in and around the Appalachian area any
civilian sightings of
scp-6448 are to be handled by mobile
task force gamma 4 or the green Stags
any possible deaths resulting from
scp-6448 will be blamed on hiking
accidents and any reported sightings can
be explained away with chronic wasting
disease CWD occasionally referred to as
zombie deer disease is a prion disease
affecting members of the servide family
symptoms of the illness include loss of
motor function control and damage to
decision making as well as gradual
degradation of all mental faculties it
is 100 fatal however though the disease
does exist most recorded cases of it in
the Appalachian region can actually be
attributed to instances of
scp-6448 any captured instances of
scp-6448 should be transported to
site-44 for the cryptozoology division's
containment and study on November 29
2019 they finally got their chance to
bring a not deer into custody the green
Stags were able to capture an instance
of
scp-6448 with a help from MTF new 7
hammer down and their heavy Vehicles
Division as well as some experimental
shock rifles one not deer was knocked
unconscious in the conflict and its body
was loaded onto an armored helicopter
and flown straight to site-44 in Essex
England at the site it was then placed
in a reinforced steel containment cell
and heavily sedated this entire process
went off without a hitch as the entity
began to regain Consciousness
cryptozoology specialist F Oz watched it
through a one-way glass window and
attempted to speak to it through the
intercom greetings
scp-6448 researcher Oz began at the
sound of his voice the creature jumped
to its feet staring at the intercom can
you understand me we've seen your Genius
speak English just fine in the past the
animal did not answer but began licking
one of its legs and behaving as if it
were an ordinary deer researcher raw
aside impatiently please we know your
secret the knocked deer stopped what it
was doing freezing completely still as
it listened to the words admittedly it
wasn't exactly well kept if you just
look at yourself for more than a few
seconds it is very clear that you're not
normal at this the creature which had
been facing away from the window
swiveled its neck 180 degrees breaking
its own spine with an audible crack it
stared unblinking at the window and
directly at researcher Oz Oz turned to
the containment staff suddenly anxious I
thought you said this was one way the
staff assured him that it was and there
was no way the not dear could see him
still its eyes were locked directly on
his face he shook off the sense of
unease and continued his line of
questioning are you something imitating
dear it is clear that if so you possess
basic anatomical knowledge of them
though details are clearly faulty in
fact a better question would be how if
in fact you are not what you pretend to
be the not deer opened its mouth at this
revealing unusually sharp teeth it moved
its jaws if attempting to speak but only
a choking sound came out
shall we move on Oz asked what I'm more
concerned with here is why you take on
people is it a vendetta spiked food for
the first time in the interview the not
deer blinked it was an unnatural
movement forced and deliberate like the
creature was attempting to engage in an
ordinary Behavior rather than actually
experiencing an involuntary impulse
responding is mandatory research draws
prompted the creature did not react if
you will not comply moz's tone grew
Stern frustrated maybe you'd like to see
your brand new containment cell at last
The Entity spoke
pictures
research its voice resembled the
distorted version of Oz's research what
kind of Oz wasn't able to finish his
question July 7
1947 the creature said before ramming
into the one-way glass and cracking it
as Oz stumbled backwards from the force
the creature collapsed on the ground
seizing and screaming as its abdomen get
the Stags in here now Oz cried out but
it was too late the black mass of
something shiny and tendered leaped out
of the not deer scuttling around the
cell before shattering the window and
leaving the empty shell of a deer behind
the site-44 breach system activated and
attempted to initiate emergency
containment protocols but the mysterious
black mass escaped its sector made its
way toward the main exit broke through
the glass of the front exit door and
vanished into the Shrubbery outside the
escaped anomaly could not be found and
recontained ever since this incident
there have been a record-breaking number
of chronic wasting disease cases
identified in D here in the surrounding
area as well as an unprecedented
increase in UFO reports further research
is currently ongoing but it is unknown
whether we will ever truly know what
these creatures are only one thing is
for certain they are definitely not dear
before we start today's video we need to
ask you a question are you alone in the
room seriously are you alone you may
think the room around you is empty but
how can you really know that right think
of the technology out there being
developed by groups like DARPA the CIA
or even the SCP Foundation secret agents
in cloaking suits could be standing
around you right now watching your every
move without you even knowing you could
tell someone about this but if you did
they'd think you're crazy and nobody
believes crazy people do they sometimes
people's whole worlds just collapse one
day they're living happy successful
lives with families and friends who love
and and care about them then the next
day they're truly convinced that the US
government is tapping not only their
phone calls and their emails but their
thoughts perhaps even putting dangerous
brain waves directly into their mind or
they start to believe that those loving
family members and Friends seek to do
them harm maybe they start to believe
their food is poisoned and stop eating
causing them to waste away from
malnutrition most terrifying of all
maybe they start to see things that
nobody else could see monsters that defy
rationality and shake the very Soul
terrible terrible things these are all
sadly relatively common symptoms of
someone suffering from a severe case of
schizophrenia a mental illness with a
wide range of detrimental effects to
sufferers first and foremost giving them
an incredibly complicated relationship
with reality there's sadly a lot of
misconceptions in the media about people
who suffer from illnesses like
schizophrenia painting them as unstable
individuals who present a danger to the
people around them in reality people
with a condition like these are three
times more likely to be a victim of a
violent crime and they're also more
likely to be a victim of something else
too like we said earlier sometimes
people's worlds just collapse and in
severe cases they might simply drop off
the map and nine times out of ten the
reason for that is
scp-870 the maybe they're monsters take
the experience of Katrina Wayne she was
an office temp in Tallahassee Florida
with an undiagnosed case of mild
schizophrenia for the most part she was
able to operate just fine at her job
getting her work done at a satisfactory
level while also maintaining a decent
social life after hours it came as a
shock to everyone when she began
screeching horrifically in the middle of
the office she backed herself up against
the wall picking up nearby objects and
throwing them into the aisles at some
invisible Foe and this isn't a metaphor
there really was as an invisible foe
moving towards her and only she could
truly see it seeing the huge scaly body
of a mature alligator from the Florida
Everglades moving towards you would be
scary enough on its own but this wasn't
any ordinary alligator its long
reptilian head had three eyes instead of
two and it moved towards her on eight
huge articulated spider legs it was like
something straight out of a nightmare
Katrina was put on leave due to a
stress-induced mental breakdown and
prescribed a course of antipsychotic
medication by a psychiatrist she
disappeared from her home without a
trace a mere two weeks later or take the
story of Daryl Simon he was a mechanic
working in Michigan with a family
history of schizophrenia though he'd
never been officially diagnosed himself
he was working on the engine of a
vintage Corvette when something strange
happened his garage began to fill up
with smoke he considered that at first
perhaps it was some kind of engine
malfunction causing smoke to belch out
of the old Corvette's tailpipe but then
he saw something standing in the smoke a
human figure Daryl suddenly felt a
profound sense of dread seeping into his
mind he grabbed a monkey wrench and
began to slowly approach the Intruder
standing in the smoke it was only when
he was already too close that he
realized the figure wasn't just standing
in the smoke it was made of smoke the
second he noticed this the figure's eyes
opened glowing red its Smoky face opened
into a wide toothy mouth and let out an
ear-splitting shriek Daryl suddenly
found himself running as the creature
gave Chase he threw his wrench as it ran
it breathed through the creature's
semi-intangible form Daryl was found
later that day huddled in the corner of
his garage muttering incoherently after
seeing a mental health professional and
sharing his story he was given a
schizophrenia diagnosis he was given a
mix of talk therapy and medication and
seemed to be improving over time he
would occasionally report hallucinations
of the man made of smoke watching from
the corner of his eye but it was
dismissed as nothing more than that a
hallucination a monthly later he was
gone never to be seen again but he
wasn't the only one to fall victim to
the anomaly Shirley Nicholson a retiree
whose schizophrenic symptoms developed
later in life was having a quiet evening
in her home when she first encountered
an instance of scp-870 she was watching
a game show on television when she heard
a strange noise coming from her kitchen
a rustling like someone was messing with
the food inside her fridge of course she
always had a tendency to hear things
which was why she wasn't that nervous
when she got up and walked to the
kitchen that sense of confidence didn't
last long when she entered the kitchen
she saw the fridge door open with the
back half of what looked like a giant
ant emerging from it her breath caught
in her throat that giant ant which
seemed to be eating the food inside her
fridge suddenly froze seeming to realize
that Shirley had entered the room when
it backed out of the fridge surely
couldn't help but scream instead of
antennas and mandibles the giant ant had
a grinning human face as Shirley Scream
the giant ants human face began to
cackle with sadistic Glee its jaw began
to stretch open impossibly wide exposing
the never-ending Darkness within Shirley
turned and ran as the creature skittered
towards her at a frightening speed
adrenaline kicked in and surely ran for
her life as the monster pursued her
through the house it was only when she
ran outing to the street and was seen by
others in this bizarre Outburst that the
horrifying ant monster seemed to
disappear and several weeks after her
schizophrenia diagnosis Shirley
Nicholson sadly disappeared too before
she vanished she made a panicked 9-1-1
call where she screamed down the line
that the monster had come back no
explanation has yet to be found but
there are more cases to be investigated
still Don Jones who had a documented
history with schizophrenia had his
scp-870 experience while waiting for the
bus out of town late one October evening
he was checking his phone at the bus
stop when he saw a figure shuffling
towards him in the distance he tried to
ignore Jordan at First Years of therapy
had taught him to try his best to ignore
these strange little anomalies he had
been medicated for years and while
occasionally he had minor episodes he'd
live with the condition for long enough
now that he'd learn how to cope that was
when the strange shuffling figure got
closer Don looked up just for a moment
to see the thing coming towards him out
of the dark it was about the size of a
child though a little shorter because of
how far the creature was hunched over
literally hunched The Entity had a
rather prominent Hunchback but this
wasn't nearly as noticeable as the
thing's face it had the head of a
particularly mangy looking parrot its
curved beak caked in what looked like
old blood this was Stranger than some of
the hallucinations he'd suffered in the
past it looked more tangible more real
even after years of medication and
therapy he felt nervous as the thing
approached him on some subconscious
level he knew the thing intended to harm
him in one way or another when it opened
its mouth and sunk the bladed tip of his
speak into Don's hand he knew that he
wasn't dealing with any mundane fantasy
here he screamed and ran off into the
night the monster giving Chase he later
reported the incident to the police but
his fears were written off when his
medical history came to light everyone
just assumed the man was experiencing
another episode and that the wound in
his hand was self-inflicted of course as
you've probably gathered by this point
poor Don Jones would disappear Without a
Trace not long after still the
testimonies get freakier a warehouse
security guard Alex Landry had his
terrifying encounter while on the job he
was on his nightly Patrol when he heard
a strangely soft skittering noise coming
from inside the warehouse he deployed
his flashlight and ran inside after
radioing for assistance he was expecting
maybe an escaped animal or a young
hoodlum messing around inside what he
didn't expect was a face-to-face
encounter with pure Terror as his
flashlight beam traced its way up to the
top of the warehouse he saw a monster
crawling across the ceiling it was a
giant 15 foot long centipede but instead
of having normal centipede legs it had
scores of twitching grasping human arms
he was found in a comatose state by his
partner and spent the brief rest of his
life in a psychiatric facility before
you guessed it disappearing Without a
Trace and most exhilaratingly we come to
The Tale of Mr Holgate which both ends a
little more hopeful for him but paints a
grim picture of what happened to
everyone else Mr Holgate had encountered
a spider-like creature with a freakish
number of legs which he soon realized
only he could see during his periods of
observation he'd seen the creature both
devour a ruler as in the measurement
device not a king as well as swallow a
human whole after an extended period of
stalking the victim leaving nothing
behind just like the scp-870 instances
had done to all of their other victims
when the monster eventually came for
Holgate he was ready it ran screeching
towards him on its tomb many legs and
Holgate whipped out a gun and shot it
the foundation had prioritized the
capture or destruction of scp-870 it's
believed to be not a single instance but
an entire species living out there
preying on humans and hiding in the
space between our perceptions even two
schizophrenic people looking at the same
instance will report seeing completely
different entities the monsters are all
the more dangerous due to the fact that
sufferers of severe schizophrenia often
report hallucinations of strange
monsters or entities so their pleas for
help are often ignored by neurotypical
authorities neurotypical meaning those
who don't experience any form of mental
illness personality disorder or
developmental condition people who can
never see scp-870 coming until they're
already being swallowed whole the lead
researcher on the scp-870 case follows
up the file on the monsters with an
ominous note that leaves little comfort
for even those of us who don't suffer
from schizophrenia the note reads I
personally you don't believe that the
schizophrenics are really seeing as CP
870 Folly they can just see it more than
us we don't see it because our brains
aren't made to see it the schizophrenics
their brains are wired up just that tiny
bit differently than they can see it
just a tiny bit more these things have
the perfect camouflage and we simply are
unable to see through it to return to
what we said at the very beginning of
this video look around the room and
answer our question are you alone now at
least you know the answer to that
question may not be as simple as it
seems the Clank of heavy metal bars
echoing through the building usually
kept Avi up at night but he never
thought that he would ever come to miss
that sound one day as he tossed and
turned in his uncomfortable bunk he
couldn't help that the noise reminded
him of how confined he was and how
trapped he felt within it had been a
mistake and honest and completely
unpredictable mistake on the nights that
sleep evaded him he'd always replayed
the events over and over again his
daughter Callie calling him out of the
blue her distorted uncontrollable sobs
playing into his ear over the phone Avi
remember jumping into the car and
flooring the accelerator rain drumming
against the windshield as he drove all
the way across town to her apartment in
the early hours of the morning and then
there was the scene that awaited him as
he stepped through the door the mess
that had been of her kitchen covering
the floor smeared up the walls even
dripping off the ceiling it all stayed
there as Avi debated with his daughter
about what they should do next she was
crying begging for her dad's help
suggesting that they should clean the
place from top to bottom and hide any
evidence scattered around the apartment
laying in his cell all those months
later he sometimes wondered why he said
no to that idea instead they came up
with a story a falsified version of
events Avi made Kali swear to stick to
it no matter what and through heavy sobs
she agreed then after they'd been over
every detail and had it perfect Avi got
back in his car and drove to the nearest
police precinct to turn himself in all
while taking the fall pleading guilty in
court and being sentenced to prison he
reminded himself over and over that he
was doing it for Kali no matter what she
had done whatever accidents had happened
she was still his kid and he would do
anything to protect her but that was
part of what made it sting so bad not
being locked up but not getting to see
her despite making requests after
request Avi was denied visitation rights
when seeing his daughter and knowing she
was alright were the only things that
would have made this struggle easier it
was after his 20th request that a guard
informed Avi that he was being moved at
first he assumed movement to another
part of the prison maybe with more lack
security and the right to see Kali but
they didn't mean moved they meant
transferred into the care of an
organization Avi came to know as the SCP
Foundation it was different here the
kind of people he was locked up with as
a member of d-class personnel were some
of the most heinous criminals on the
planet but there was something else
going on something weirder Avi would
overhear Whispers and rumors from the
other d-classes they'd talk of
experiments conducted by the foundation
with them as the Lab Rats
d-14164 the researcher greeted him as he
was pulled into a side room flanked on
all sides by armed Foundation guards
yours is quite the interesting case no
priors no criminal affiliations of any
kind hardly any family to testify to
your innocence and yet what you did now
that takes some guts if you pardon the
pun so it's all true then Avi replied
solemnly you're here to say you want to
experiment on me I wouldn't call it an
experiment per se the researcher smiled
smugly let's use the word expedition has
a nicer ring to it don't you think an
expedition to wear he asked I'm afraid I
can't tell you that but I won't go Avi
Shrugged listen closely d14164 the SCP
Foundation has
well let's say a considerable influence
across the globe what we're asking you
to agree to is involvement and possibly
one of the most dangerous operations we
have ever conducted now as unappealing
as that might sound allow me to sweeten
the deal should you say yes agree to
take part and follow our instructions
then you might find that the
foundation's influence may be rather
beneficial to you should you survive the
researcher paused to push a document
across the table close enough for Avi to
read a clean record that one nasty
mistake wiped clean for good on top of
that an immediate release and a new
identity you'd have a second chance Mr
Garrett both of you and your daughter
would and what if I say no obvious
bluntly well that's your prerogative the
researcher replied and we won't be able
to detain you after releasing evidence
of your innocence so you'll be free no
matter what oh although your daughter
will of course be remanded into custody
given that she is
maybe once we get her move to d-class
she might be more willing to cooperate
than her dear old dad under the table
avi's hands were shaking with rage he
clenched his fist so furiously that the
Cuffs felt tighter around his wrists the
hate in his eyes was palpable as he
glared at the researcher it was bad
enough that they had backed him into a
corner put him in a situation where in
saying yes or no would be equally
catastrophic but what felt worse was
that they knew what Kali had done and
they were using that as a threat taking
a deep breath Avi steadied himself
before finally speaking up again just
tell me what you want me to do instantly
he'd felt like he'd been thrown
headfirst into a commotion he could
barely keep up with no sooner had he
said that Avi had been LED Away by a
team of foundation guards while the
researcher followed rattling off vague
information about the Expedition Guided
by the armed escort into another room
Avi was flocked by more Foundation staff
strapping electronic equipment over the
outside of his orange prisoner Garb one
piece of it was to monitor his heart
rate another was a portable camera to
record his surroundings although those
were among the few details that he was
actually able to catch during all the
activity Avi couldn't help but notice
how nobody had even mentioned just where
he was meant to be going on this
Expedition just that the foundation
wanted to keep a close eye on him while
he was there you still haven't told me
exactly where it is I'm meant to be
going he finally spoke up or how I'm
getting there all in good time the head
researcher replied so far the only
detail you need to be aware of is this
it's dangerous a particularly hostile
environment so like a war zone aviast
the researcher smiled but to themselves
as if there was something funny about
the question and lack of understanding
it conveyed obvious attention was
quickly turned to another d-class
wearing a similar d-class uniform to him
the staff began preparing the second
convict in the same room although
without nearly as much gear as they'd
given Avi I thought I was the only one
going on this trip he stated ah don't
worry that's just the lure the
researcher explained they would only
raise more questions they won't be
accompanying you it was then Avi was led
out of the prep room and walked through
the foundation facility the place was a
hive of activity as well as noise there
were alien shrieks and whales monstrous
sounds emanating from deep in the
building muffled only slightly
underneath thick layers of concrete and
heavy steel doors on top of that there
were screams too distinctly human sounds
of pain and fear Avi tried to ignore it
as he was instructed to keep walking
feeling almost nostalgic for the Clank
of metal bars back at his old cell he
had been anticipating being taken out of
the facility towards maybe a helipad or
Runway where an aircraft would be
waiting to fly him out to his
undisclosed destination in fact even a
dock with a moored boat would have been
more within the realm of what he
expected but instead he was taken deeper
and deeper into the foundation's
sprawling complex passing testing areas
and containment levels through winding
corridors until of he was told to stop
in front of a heavy door that held a
containment area Beyond he couldn't help
but notice that the door itself looked
brand new like it had only just been
installed meanwhile the frame
surrounding it had traces of discoloring
and damage almost as if something
corrosive had melted away the previous
door hence the replacement this is it
Avi asked confused but still trying to
nudge more information out of the
foundation's staff you want me to do an
expedition within your own building yes
and no the head researcher replied still
giving next to no useful details now
this is important once you get to your
destination we need you to figure out
how to get back to us you do that and
you'll have your freedom your daughter
and your second chance surely to get
back I can just open up this door again
the prisoner said that garnered a slight
chuckle from the researcher again
seeming to find avi's lack of
understanding amusing
oh d14164 if only it was that simple the
door opened with a heaving metallic
Creak and Avi was unceremoniously pushed
inside by the guards staggering inside
catching himself before he lost his
balance and fell over he almost turned
back to start slamming his fists against
the now sealed entrance he would have
were not for the sight of something
oozing out of the wall directly in front
of him Avi stepped closer to inspect it
but withdrew his hand as he noticed
thick black droplets leaking onto the
floor the substance hissed as it made
contact with the ground like it was
burning through corroding whatever it
came into contact with keeping himself
from touching it Avi leaned in to get a
closer look and found the grotesque face
of
scp-106 looking back at him a spindly
decrepit hand reached out of the gooey
puddle and grabbed the orange material
of avi's jumpsuit pulling up the Garment
with enough strength to tug his entire
body forward in a blind panic Avi tried
to swipe the old man's rotting arm away
feeling an intense burning almost like a
chemical scalding his skin as the same
black ooze burn through his clothing and
started to singe his chest another hand
shot forward out of the puddle on the
wall a clawed thumb puncturing avi's
side he screamed in pain as he felt the
blistering digit Pierce into him while
the rest of the fingers pulled him
closer still to the wall using the hole
in his side like a handle the stench of
his own burning flesh mixed with the air
of rotting Decay that scp-106 brought
with it everywhere the decaying face of
the old man peered through the black
slime on the wall its mouth locked in a
sadistic Sinister grin as Avi found
himself pulled inside it almost felt
like he had fallen asleep in the bathtub
and woke up gasping and sputtering just
having narrowly avoided drowning except
now he was waking up in an entirely
different space the transition there
having done little to deal the pain of
his injuries sitting up as he arrived in
his new dark and desolate surroundings
Avi gripped his side and winced at the
Searing pain then the sun smell of
burning plastic crawled up his nostrils
and downed the back of his throat most
of the equipment the foundation had
strapped onto him was melting the heart
rate monitor and Camera corroding
covered in more of that black sludge
standing up gritting his teeth through
the pain of his wounds Avi quickly
removed the devices as carefully as he
could it was far beyond caring about the
foundation's Expedition right now he
just wanted to get back out of wherever
the hell this place was checking over
his shoulder the Slick corrosive puddle
he'd been pulled through was already
gone at any rate Avi didn't particularly
like the idea of going back that way so
was relieved although he'd soon find out
that relief was perhaps misplaced he had
barely a few moments to examine his
surroundings not that there was much he
could see besides endless dark corridors
and the withered figure of the old man
it had reappeared looking like it was
far off in the distance before in a
split second the gap between
scp-106 and Avi had closed the creature
tilted its bald skeletal head as it
looked at him and he got a full
unobscured Glimpse at its sunken eyes
and face locked in a Perpetual lipless
grin the rotting wrinkly flesh of the
old man's body was oozing more and more
of that dark disgusting mucus droplets
of it landing on avi's clothing and
burning holes right through one hand
still applying pressure to his side Avi
turned and tried to run as far and fast
as his body was able if getting away was
his sole objective he wanted out as
quick as possible anything to get away
from the nightmarish creature he had now
found himself trapped with running
didn't seem to work though he was sure
he had made it at least a few feet the
old man was still standing behind him
but looked to be at more of a distance
that was until Avi noticed his legs they
were running backwards each step he had
taken away from scp-106 was being
reversed rebound like on an old VHS tape
bringing him back closer and closer to
the creature's clutches its claws pushed
painfully through avi's back as It
reversed time right back to the point
where he had turned to run away as the
old man reached through him more of that
burn acidic pain started eating away at
its captive d-class prey with Avi
letting out a pain scream it wasn't
until several minutes in that he
realized something that hurt almost just
as bad
scp-106 could have killed him in an
instant that much was clear but it
hadn't it had chosen not to instead it
was torturing him prolonging the pain
Avi was experiencing because it wanted
him to suffer with all its strength
scp-106 hurled him several feet until
avi's burning corroded body collided
with a hard surface a wall with a loud
crack the old man then manipulated time
within his pocket Dimension causing Avi
to fly backward through the air back
into the creature's corrosive grip it
allowed time to keep winding back
undoing all the damage it had done so
far as much as Avi was relieved to be
rid of the Searing pain he was in a sick
worry deep in the pit of his stomach
told him that this wasn't an act of
Mercy the old man just wanted to make
him suffer all over again he lost track
of how long it went on for
scp-106 taking sickly and hurting his
captive only to reverse the time within
the pocket Dimension and do it all again
each time felt just like the first made
worse by the fact that Avi never had a
chance to get used to the pain to become
numb to it instead every moment the
torture started was just like the first
time in fact it technically was
screaming in agony Avi had no clue if he
had been there for hours days months or
even years had any time passed at all
how many times had the old man done this
to him only to reverse time and do it
all over again letting the pain begin
Anew every few tries the old man would
release Avi for a moment but once again
it was never done out of any sense of
Mercy or kindness it was so it could
hunt him still Avi ran every time as far
and fast as he could searching every
corner of that dark desolate place for
some kind of a way out a portal home
another one of those corrosive black
puddles a big door with exit written on
it in big letters but instead all he
found was
scp-106 or rather the old man found him
it was hunting him again Avi had no idea
how many times this made panting he
slowed to a halt trying to catch his
breath reaching out in the dark he put a
hand against a nearby hard surface a
wall then felt a crack under his hand
examining closer although he could
barely see it Avi could feel with
absolute certainty that this wall had
been damaged just a little it was the
same one the exact same wall he had been
thrown against who knew how long ago but
the point was it was still cracked from
where his body had hit it even after the
old man had reversed time to hurt Avi
over and over again the damage had
stayed he had no way of knowing if it
would work or how long it would take but
it might have been a way out desperately
off he slammed his fist against the wall
feeling pain shooting through his
fingers and up into his arm as it
collided with a solid surface nothing
changed winding back the other arm he
hid it again still nothing Avi could
hear the old man shuffling closer behind
him could sense his hands reaching out
closer to torture him again he let it
happen striking one last blow against
the wall before it finally reached him
and the pain began once more only to be
reversed so that
scp-106 could do it again but now he had
a goal each time the creature rewound
time and undid all the damage to its
captive's body Avi went looking for that
same wall feeling across every surface
until he reached it again the damage was
still there only a tiny crack for now
but time despite being under the old
man's control in this pocket Dimension
was on avi's side whenever he made it
back to the wall he started to punch it
again pounding one fist against it after
the other he didn't relent despite the
pain it caused him he told himself it
would be worth it if it meant a way out
even the times when the bones in his
hands broke and he was flimsily striking
at the cracked wall with shattered
fingers he didn't stop it would be worth
it it had to be no matter how long it
took he would gradually chip away at the
wall more and more every time as cp106
would find Avi and when it did it would
hurt him the pain he'd put himself
through trying to break down the wall
helped numb some of the torture before
the old man reset everything again then
the Hun began again and Avi went back to
making his gradual dent in the wall the
whole time he remembered he was doing it
for Kali for his freedom and a fresh
start until eventually it stopped Avi
had no idea how many times he'd struck
the wall but it had been enough to Start
Tumbling through it slightly both hands
blood and broken again but this time the
old man didn't appear it had stopped
screaming in Rage Avi started throwing
himself at the indented wall trying
desperately to Chip Away more completely
unaware that scp-106 had left him alone
in its pocket Dimension back in their
facility the foundation had lost contact
with obvious recording devices over
three hours ago at which point they had
initiated their recall protocol injuring
the d-class they had chosen as a lure
sure enough the old man had reappeared
from his pocket Dimension following the
pain screams to come and finish the lure
off there was no sign of Avi and with a
sign the head researcher simply noted
down
scp-106 pocket Dimension Escape test
result test inconclusive modern
cognitive Neuroscience tells us that our
memories are about as reliable as a
weatherman at your local news channel
when a couple is asked how did you first
meet they are lured into romanticized
reflection they might recall locking
eyes at a school dance they might recall
the night being just perfect despite the
truth being far from it we don't
remember the spilled punch the stepped
on toes or this
stuttering we only remember the X's and
O's our memory doesn't find the needle
by sifting through the haystack but
rather by lighting a match and setting
the barn Ablaze until All That Remains
is the small piece of silver shining
through the smoke in this way our
memories are our best friends they know
exactly when to lie to us feeding us
misinformation about the past to satisfy
ourselves in the present because if
humans were capable of writing and
recalling accurate personal accounts of
their history our memories would be
stiff unmarketable literature and when a
book gets boring we tend to tap out just
the same when our lives get monotonous
we tend to give up so we have our faulty
biased brains to thank us for our
perceived happiness and fulfillment are
inaccurate memory systems consequently
help us hide trauma contrive purpose and
Infuse unique importance into an
otherwise banal existence but let it be
known not all cerebral restructurings
are gifts from psychology some are
curses from scps which of these two
possibilities is more existentially
terrifying is up to you
scp-5040 is a non-existent Japanese
horror film entitled Tears of Blood
which spontaneously manifests in human
memories
scp-5040 is a master of persuasion those
affected by scp-5040 will remember going
to see the film even when their supposed
attendance would contradict empirical
evidence it manipulates the Mind into
unwavering Faith while humans
occasionally stumble upon the
self-awareness to question their
recollection there are no documented
instances of an individual doubting this
specific memory somehow beyond the
foundation understanding
scp-5040 manages to suspend the
skepticism of its victims they accept
the memory as Canon as brute fact
victims of scp-5040 do not need a ticket
stub to know they have been to the
theater and scp-5040 afflictions can
occur any place where movies are shown
it even transcends laws and navigates
social norms in cultures where its
content would usually be prohibited by
regulations and frowned upon by the
public it still inserts itself into the
memory of its prey and once that memory
is planted it's an event that can't be
forgotten like the birth of your first
child like your favorite football team
winning the Super Bowl like the employee
number you punch in and out of work
every day for the rest of your life it
stamps itself into the Forefront of the
subject's brain waving its arm pleading
to be recognized begging for attention
descriptions of the film are always
similar in nature as are the
circumstances and events surrounding the
viewing however reports of scp-540's
story and characters are never fully
consistent from one subject to the next
and the film's setting subplots
character names and much of the dialogue
are different for each viewer whether
this is scp-5040s intent or inadequacy
is unclear casting also varies and
appears largely arbitrary a broad
variety of Japanese performers and
entertainment personalities both living
and deceased have been said to star in
the film even when the actor in question
has no real life associations with the
horror genre imagine famous Japanese
actor Pat Morita better known as Mr
Miyagi from the karate kid being the
lead in a horror film despite the fact
this would be a noticeably strange
casting decision
scp-5040 would still be taken seriously
despite any and all deviations from
expectations of the medium
scp-5040 is seen as legitimate kinks in
its design are overlooked by the viewer
similar to how our sleeping selves most
often don't recognize we are dreaming
even when we encounter flying horses
friends with banana fingers and
leprechauns playing Pot Limit Omaha in
Chris Hemsworth's basement this may be
because despite all of its quirks the
film's core is sturdy it's beginning
middle and end are always in agreement
it doesn't stray from Robert McKee's
Universal structure of story not even
the sick twisted M Night Shyamalan
himself could have created a cinematic
experience quite like this after
conducting more than 300 interviews
researchers have constructed a detailed
synopsis of scp-5040's most consistent
story elements and the most common
sequence of events associated with the
viewer's memory of their screening
attendance there is no matinee with this
movie screenings always begin at Sunset
if there are obstacles standing in the
way of the subject's attendance
scp-5040 will see them removed dentist
appointments drinks with a friend a long
procrastinated date with the treadmill
all these commitments for that day and
time will be pushed down the subject's
list of priorities making way for the
movie they will learn that their plans
have been canceled or resolved one way
or another the dentist's office burned
to the ground your friend is suddenly
sober the model of treadmills at your
gym have been recalled somehow someway
time is freed up and when life is kind
enough to offer respite from personal
and social obligations it is modern
humans instinct to sit down and veg out
at this moment the subjects decide to
see a movie at a nearby theater upon
arrival the theater looks to be an
entity in its own right long lines of
patrons are like limbs extending from
its Center box office bright blocky
letters forming the film's title run
across the Marquee like a cheap tattoo
it is truly
Madness a frenzied crowd gathers at the
box office pushing and shoving clawing
at the glass partition for a ticket the
entire theater has been reserved for
this special event a one-time only
screening of a rare critically acclaimed
film admission is entirely free but is
it actually free or has the cost just
not declared itself when the subject
reaches the auditorium they scanned
their eyes over the sea of people heads
emerge from the backs of almost every
seat they can only find one empty space
and they have to shuffle like a crab to
get past the mass of other viewers in
their seat they notice that a large
number of people throughout the audience
are wearing disposable face masks the
woman sitting next to the subject's
right wears one such mask as does the
woman on their left and before you think
well that isn't so weird it's important
to note that all of these accounts were
taken years before certain recent events
patrons continue to pack into the
theater despite every chair being filled
more and more people enter the aisles
become overflow seating regulations of
Max occupancy are dismissed in the
darkness of the room all that can be
clearly seen are shapes the rectangle
that is the screen the hundreds of
circles that are the heads of the
audience but there is a shape that feels
misplaced what appears to be the letter
P sticks up from the crowd a thin line
with a bulge protruding from the top the
specificity of its origin is difficult
to Define but once the subject's eyes
adjust to the dark they notice it's an
IV pole carrying a bag of unknown fluid
however there is no clear indication of
who it is connected to furthermore they
notice one of the masked audience
members is wearing a hospital gown there
is little time to assess any of these
strange visuals because there are no
trailers or advertisements before the
film as soon as the audience is settled
into whatever space they might find
temporarily habitable the theater goes
silent and the film Begins the film
opens with the female protagonists going
about mundane activities in her
day-to-day life a phone call interrupts
her it is an unknown party who tells her
that a loved one has been hospitalized
for one reason or another the
protagonist drops what she's doing to
accept the call to action on her way to
the hospital however she is attacked by
a male assailant and loses Consciousness
the protagonist wakes up in a fog unable
to make sense of her surroundings but
the audience understands that wherever
she is she is in deep trouble she's in a
desolate and unfamiliar building with
her arms and legs bound she is
accompanied by a number of other female
captives some of whom still remain
seemingly unconscious or possibly dead
the woman briefly discussed their
strategy to escape but they are
interrupted when the kidnapper appears
descriptions of hairstyle eye color and
wardrobe would fall short in showing us
who this character really is instead his
Swift and decisive actions do the
talking he sees one of the women crying
and kills her without hesitation the
kidnapper reveals to the woman the code
he intended to operate under he would
release the captives after 24 hours but
only under the condition that they do
not cry during the film the kidnapper
demonstrates various forms of physical
and psychological torture on the group
of women despite their best efforts the
captives are unable to hold back their
tears and one by one they are murdered
until only the protagonist remains
frustrated by the protagonist's
unremarkable resolve the kidnapper takes
more Extreme Measures increasing
intensity of her torture however the
protagonist is not one to be messed with
despite being tormented she seems in
control of the situation she doesn't
succumb to the traditional dynamics of
torture even while on the wrong end of
the bat she isn't afraid to swing she
fights back how she can she mocks and
insults her captor and it's then she
finds his weakness although a physically
empowering villain he is
fragile her grit frustrates him causing
him to lose focus and become noticeably
rattled as the protagonist continues to
weaken her kidnapper with words the
subject in the audience notices what
seems to be a slight echo in the
dialogue they look up to see if
something is wrong with the speakers
they even wonder if this is a stylistic
decision made by the director but then
they notice where it is coming from they
eventually realize that the two masked
women sitting beside them are quietly
repeating every line of dialogue as it
occurs their lips moving causes their
masks to shake softly with each word the
air from their Whispers blows the cloth
away from their mouth only for the mass
to collapse back in when the syllable is
completed if the subject looks even
closer they will see that the lower half
of the woman's masks are saturated with
saliva things don't get any more
pleasant when the subject shifts their
gaze down the woman's body just near
their waists their hands are clasped
together so tightly that their
fingernails are digging into their skin
they tremble and fidget as if having
taken on the burden of the world's
anxiety and no medication can calm them
down fingernails dig deeper into their
skin drawing blood and foreshadowing the
film's finale at the film's climax the
kidnapper approaches the protagonist
with a double-edged razor blade and
announces that even if she is freed she
will spend the rest of her life horribly
disfigured this leads to an argument
between the two the subtext of which
alludes to themes such as nature of
inner and outer beauty the value of
women in society and the societal stigma
against expressions of vulnerability the
argument on the surface however does not
sound sophisticated or profound there is
no consolation for a fight having
emotional depths at the end of the day
the blows will always feel more physical
than intellectual eventually the
kidnapper loses patience and grabs the
protagonist by the shoulders and slams
her to the floor he reaches out his
hands and grabs her by the face the
subject's attention is again pulled from
the screen when when they hear groaning
from every direction the wordless hums
filled the theater with a sense of worry
and uneasiness so much so that the
subject feels the room getting smaller
as the air polluted with angst grows
thicker as the subject brings their eyes
back to the film they see the kidnapper
gripping the protagonist's lower lip
between his thumb and forefinger
squeezing tight as to pop her lip like a
balloon the kidnapper then takes the
razor blade to the victim's lips he
pauses to mock the protagonist and while
he does this blinded by pride and
arrogance she jolts into action grabbing
the razor right out of his hands with
her teeth she follows up her burglary
with assault her neck steps forward and
in a blur she stabs the kidnapper's eyes
out it happens and
the kidnapper has no time to react blood
spills from his face screams pour out of
his mouth during this time the
protagonist Maneuvers the razor into her
fingers she hacks away at her bindings
but they are stubborn and resist her
sighing the battle continues and the
kidnapper is able to tear off the
victim's lips entirely she looks like a
monster now as the kidnapper smiles and
celebrates his wrongdoings the
protagonist finishes freeing herself and
slits the kidnapper's throat with the
razor the protagonist locates the exit
and scrambles towards it as the
kidnapper bleeds to death on the cold
hard floor the protagonist then speaks
her final words due to her injuries her
voice is muffled and raspy she Bears
down and calmly speaks one last time she
mocks the kidnapper telling him that he
cried tears of blood and therefore had
to die according to his own rules during
this climax it is reported that the
subjects experience a sense of dread
unique to any other Terror ever fight
strangely the female appeared not to
correspond to the scene in the film at
all it is a feeling entirely separate
from the viewing experience as if for a
moment the subject is taken out of the
moment in time and transported to a
realm composed only of fear and anxiety
but just as quickly as they left they
returned the foundation sees it worth
mentioning that this peculiar moment
happens to occur during the film's most
clearly recalled scene while
descriptions of violence vary from one
viewer to the next the climax is
unshakable and its consistency this is
further evidence that scp-5040 has a
core Foundation that remains intact
false memories are given validity by our
peers when we tell a story the
inaccuracies are often the best parts
the exaggerated drama the rearranged
sequence of events the jokes you thought
of in retrospect but weaved into later
accounts while a Storyteller knows when
to lie a good Storyteller knows how to
not get caught
scp-5040 captivates its audience but it
seems to know how much it can get away
with by providing a consistent objective
truth a climax that is reported the same
across all accounts
scp-5040 insists even if only briefly on
being a credible film not just a random
sequence of 24 frames per second eyes
back to the screen the film abruptly
cuts to an unspecified point in the
future now wearing a face mask to hide
her disfigured mouth no different than
the one seen worn in the theater the
protagonist walks down the street to her
apartment indifferent to the crowd of
Paparazzi that follows her it is clear
that this is now just a part of her life
the lights flash on her face when she
reaches her bedroom the protagonist
slowly pulls down her mask face free
from cloth she stares at herself in the
mirror it is silent what she sees is
less notable than what she doesn't the
lower portion of her face is gone she
focuses only on that it's hard to know
if she will ever see into her own eyes
again her days might forever be fixed on
what she can't get back and through
those eyes that long to see more she
sheds a single tear over the course of
several minutes her weeping gradually
builds into frenzied sobs and shrieks it
can first be misinterpreted as bad
acting a case of doing too much but as
the crying carries onward it's
understood that the horror in her
wallowing is all too real the film cuts
to Black and the credits roll but the
sound of the protagonist's cries
continue to play with no other audio
until the credit reel ends and even then
in silence it's hard to say if she ever
stopped crying audience members remain
silent after the movie ends exchanging
only Whispers as they exit the theater
feet step over small red puddles and
stains on the theater floor as if they
are sticky puddles of soda those who
remain past this point experience an
escalating feeling of unwelcomeness
until sitting and staying is more
physically demanding than getting up and
walking out some experiences will stay
with you forever even if they never
actually happened rock paper scissors a
simple hand game dating back to the Han
Dynasty of Imperial China it is a
decisive game between two players with
the only outcomes being Win Lose or Draw
we're quite familiar with rock paper
scissors here at the SCP Foundation as
the guards are often seen playing
intense rounds of the game to determine
who will be the Unlucky Soul chosen to
secure one of the various cutter class
as CPS during a given week in most cases
this use of rock paper scissors is
accepted as a largely harmless and Fair
Way for defensive Personnel to arrange
their chefs the reason for this is that
the results of rock paper scissors are
generally random as there are very few
ways for an individual's skill to
influence the game or so one might think
in reality rock paper scissors is a
deeply psychological game and this is
mainly because of its origin as a
contest between fellow human beings the
average human is vulnerable to making
errors and falling into patterns and
with only three options to keep track of
it is entirely possible for a seasoned
veteran of rock paper scissors to
predict their opponent's Choice before
any hands are thrown of course that
opponent may also commit an error of
their own by misreading the other
player's actions and thus there is
always a chance for an impulsive
decision to swing the results of the
game in either direction human
limitation is the only skill based
mechanic in the game of rock paper
scissors and that same limitation is
what in the eyes of some holds the game
back from reaching its true potential
that was the case until someone out
there discovered the rules to an
anomalous version of rock paper scissors
being spread through a mysterious email
while all attempts to trace the email
back to its original sender have left
the foundation with more questions than
answers we have been able to learn more
about the differences between the rules
of standard rock paper scissors and the
anomalous version we have given this
anomalous version of rock paper scissors
the designation
scp-4633 and unlike the classic edition
under no circumstances are any
foundation Personnel allowed to play a
game incorporating any of the
alternative rules while the ceiling for
skill and variety is theoretically much
higher in a rock paper scissors match
featuring
scp-4633 the risks to the player far
outweigh any added novelty here is how
scp-4633 functions during an average
game of rock paper scissors well average
prior to the anomalous properties taking
effect rather than being limited to
using merely rock paper or scissors as
the name of the game implies the players
gain access to a series of additional
hand gestures which upon the act of
being thrown becomes seamlessly
integrated into both players shared
understanding of the rules this alone
would be bizarre enough but the true
harm caused by scp-4633 is in the nature
of the gestures themselves when one of
the non-standard gestures Allowed by
scp-4633 is used the player's hands will
change shape in ways that under normal
circumstances would be anatomically
impossible each of these non-standard
gestures is distinct from the rest with
the only commonality being an unusual
tendency for the final gesture to
resemble biological structures often
seen in sea life one particular gesture
might cause a player to rapidly grow a
ring of additional fingers surrounding a
gaping anemone like mouth in the Palm
while another could result in the
player's entire arm flattening into a
fin-like appendage regardless of how
severe a departure from a typical human
limb the final gesture would be the
limbs and on rare occasions the entire
body of the player using the gesture
will quickly end irreversibly mutate
into the shape required to successfully
perform it while these gestures over
overwhelmingly result in forms that
would be distressing to most people the
same cognitive effect that causes the
participants to accept changes to the
rules also appears to apply to the
changes affecting their own bodies to
the players of an scp-4633 augmented
match of rock paper scissors the
non-standard gestures seem as mundane as
the original Three unfortunately the
morphic properties of scp-4633 are
practically irreversible with extreme
reconstructive surgery being required in
even the best of cases in all instances
of
scp-4633 surgical intervention is
necessary to prevent the spread of
details regarding the non-standard
gestures and their usage because of the
immediate shift in cognitive awareness
among participants all that is needed
for a new instance of scp-4633 to occur
is the faintest hint of knowledge of the
alternative rules it's even been noted
that between different groups of players
the non-standard gestures can vary
heavily or seemingly be created on the
fly as the desire to win at all costs
takes hold here are a few examples of
anomalous gestures which have been
observed during instances of
scp-4633 this list is by no means
comprehensive but it will provide an
insight into how
scp-4633 drastically Alters the existing
mechanics of the game as well as the
physique of the players the Thor Riley
gesture transforms the user's fingers
into Barbed tentacles it beats paper and
scissors but loses to rock chavoga folds
the fingers of the hand into the palm
and causes them to emerge through the
back of the Palm it allows the user to
throw a second gesture after they've
seen their opponent's Choice ashkelhas
splits the hand into a pair of poisonous
Stingers which also produce a potent
electrical current between them it has
been seen to lose to paper but seemingly
of their own will The Stingers lashed at
the opposing player and caused them to
fall unconscious three rounds later due
to the effects of the poison chosa beats
paper and two other anomalous gestures
loses to scissors rock and a third
gesture and morphs the user's arm into a
Dactyl Club similar to the front
appendage of a mantis shrimp these ergov
simply causes the player to grow three
additional thumbs on one hand the final
gesture resembles a triple thumbs up his
urugov has not been seen to beat any
gestures and the player who uses it
always seems to go on to lose the match
pagakumar causes the middle and ring to
recede into the hand while the pointer
and pinky fingers extend to resemble the
eye stalks of a snail or slug the rest
of the hand also becomes coated in a
thin layer of slime which continues to
secrete from within pagakmarg beats
scissors and paper but loses to Rock and
Another anomalous gesture known as
vayonjik incidentally Ryon Jack causes
the arm of the player using it to
elongate into a worm-like tube that
periodically spews a gout of salt water
on the opponent when vyanchek was seen
beating pagakmar the saltwater appeared
to have some adverse effect on the
latter gesture causing the eye stocks to
droop and the hand to shrivel until it
was half its original size another
anomalous gesture is grazothrog
recognized by the skin muscle and veins
of the hand turning translucent
revealing a pulsing red organ in the
interior of the Palm once gryzatharag
has been thrown the player who used it
may call out the name of one other
gesture which can no longer be used in
the current match the ukayag gesture is
a bit deceptive as it resembles Rock
when first thrown but gradually causes
the hand to condense into a lump of
inert material not dissimilar to actual
igneous rock the knuckles as well begin
to exude a superheated mineral substance
similar to molten lava ukayag
exclusively beats paper and appears to
lose to everything else many of the
gestures on record have no known name
but their function within
scp-4633's altered rules is clear from
the context in which they were used such
is the case with one anomalous gesture
which caused most of the player's hand
to withdraw into a siphon-like opening
at their wrist before the very same
orifice shot out a stream of ink into
the opposing player's eyes while there
was no lasting harm done to the opponent
by this gesture the ink did cause
temporary blindness which persisted
until they were defeated by way of their
Rock losing to paper another unknown
gesture has been seen beating both
izorogov and ukayag this gesture makes
the player's hand resemble the crest and
gas-filled body of a Pacific Mana War
these examples are only scraping the
surface of these seemingly Endless
Possibilities that scp-4633 has to offer
as you can see the anomalous hand
gestures can be just as dangerous within
the game itself as the permanent changes
they invoke in the user while the
foundation has done its best to contain
all information surrounding
scp-4633 there have been clear efforts
by several unknown known groups to push
the game into continued usage over the
past three decades instances of scp-4633
have seen increasing popularity in the
world of high-stakes gambling Perhaps it
is because of the inherent thrill of
watching two opponents trying to
strategically outwit each other with a
countless number of non-standard
gestures but more likely it is part of
the anomalous effect of
scp-4633 that the game would appeal to
those desperate to risk everything on
the slim chance of Victory this neatly
brings us to the scp-4633 related
incident which occurred aboard the
private ocean liner known as the SS
fateful Emma before the incident the
Fateful Emma would sail into
international waters twice a year each
time it would bring along a new group of
passengers seemingly selected from the
underprivileged and downcast sector of
society a grade many of these passengers
were convicts with repeat violent
offenses chosen from supermax facilities
the world over the process by by which
these inmates were chosen for a voyage
aboard the ship was not dissimilar from
the methods the foundation uses to
acquire new class D Personnel naturally
this was how the research team was able
to be tipped off about the Fateful Emma
it became apparent soon after looking
into the ship's career that the
individuals altered by the effects of
scp-4633 had been seen departing from
the ship on multiple occasions in remote
island Harbors most of the time the
individuals would also be to the best of
their ability with their metamorphized
forms carrying briefcases filled with
hundreds of thousands of dollars in cash
while Witnesses tend to write off the
strange appearances of those affected as
being the result of a deformity or
injury or more pronounced instances
dismissing the encounters as sightings
of creatures from the local mythology it
was clear to anyone familiar with
scp-4633 what was truly going on these
passengers were being made to play
pitched games of rock paper scissors
featuring scp-46 33 for massive sums of
wealth and what was worse the Grand
Prize winners were seemingly being
released back into civilization without
the knowledge of law enforcement of
course what the foundation was most
concerned about was the potential for
the large-scale leak of detailed
information involving
scp-4633 it seemed that the foundation's
latest faceless enemy had revealed
itself whatever wealthy group of
individuals was pulling the strings
behind the games aboard the SS fateful
Emma it was very likely that the ship
was also well protected by a private
Army of trained mercenaries in a display
of Swift but necessary initiative the
foundation assembled a brand new mobile
task force to be dispatched onto the
ocean liner mobile task force row 52
with the fitting code name Rochambeau
the mobile task force would board the
vessels secretly and use whatever means
necessary to prevent the spread of
scp-4633 and any evidence of the
associated non-standard hand gestures
before the Fateful Emma's next Voyage
the foundation isolated the port where
it would depart from and made sure that
the MTF agents were in position the
operation was co-captained by agent
DuBois and agent Shang both of whom
prided themselves on having
extraordinarily good luck agent Dubois
would stealthily move the majority of
the agents under his command into the
cargo hole below deck and await agent
Zhang's signal agent Zhang himself would
assume the name and identity of one of
the criminal passengers who was
intercepted before boarding by the
mobile task force the would-be
participant was subsequently detained
and brought into the foundation as a
Class D personnel as the SS faithful
Emma began to leave the harbor agent
Zhang joined the other passengers who
had been gathered together in an
enormous function hall there was little
indication of when the games would begin
and Zhang made an effort to keep a low
profile until more information was
available shortly after the ship had
officially arrived in international
waters an eccentric man entered the room
on a walkway that overlooked the rest of
the passengers he was flanked by a pair
of armed bodyguards it was plain from
the man's style of dress and demeanor
that he was both absurdly wealthy and
completely out of his mind he wore a
pure white tuxedo and a scarf that
seemed to have been made from the fur of
a Siberian tiger a pair of Dark Shades
with sequined rims obscured his eyes
from view but by far the strangest
aspect of the rich man was the fact that
emerging from the wrist of his right arm
was the eyeless head of Amore eel where
his hand should be the man spoke
addressing the entire room welcome
passengers new and old to the SS fateful
Emma while you aboard this ship your
fate is in your own hands over the next
24 hours you will have the rare
opportunity to play the greatest game of
chance that Humanity has ever known
generations of people from every
continent and every Walk of Life have
given their all to the Mastery of rock
paper scissors across nose flat door
slashes the men proceeded to speak
unusual syllables for the next minute
straight without even a pause for breath
in his report agent Zhang described the
man's voice as gaining an increasingly
loud hum as his speech continued and
that some of the syllables didn't seem
to be the product of human vocal cords
he soon concluded his string of
gibberish and resumed speaking
intelligible language as is customary we
will be utilizing the iljesh toi rules
you will Begin by selecting a single
opponent and challenging them to a best
of two of three match this is a single
elimination tournament and any
competitors who cannot otherwise
continue to engage in matches will also
be eliminated by the end of your time
here the luckiest among you will be
named the Undisputed champion of these
games and will be granted unlimited
Freedom along with the cash prize the
rest of you will have to determine your
own Fates where you all know what a way
to blows may your hands be ready your
minds be sharp and remember Winning is
Everything
with a flourish of his moray eel hand
the wealthy man finished his
introductions and promptly exited the
room agent Zhang looked at the
passengers surrounding him and saw that
they were already beginning to play Rock
Paper Scissors with each other a few had
already begun using the anomalous
gestures warping their limbs into
hideous subnautical shapes agent Zhang
gave the signal to agent DuBois and the
rest of the mobile task force to begin
the operation their target was primarily
the Moray handed man as well as any
other Close Associates that he had on
board they would capture him alive and
interrogate him into revealing the
mystery behind this illegal gambling
ring once the mercenaries were dealt
with agent Dubois team would further
command the ocean liner and navigate it
to SCP Foundation research site-45 to
await further orders as for agent Zhang
he knew what he had to do to buy time he
would participate in the ensuing rock
paper scissors tournament and eliminate
as many of the other players as possible
this he believed was the best way to
minimize the number of anomalous
gestures that would be used aboard the
ship of course he himself wouldn't be
using any of the anomalous gestures
either opting to limit himself to the
standard three this could put him at a
severe disadvantage over the course of
the competition but agent Zhang knew
better than to tempt fate still being
eliminated seemed like something he may
want to avoid even though the
consequences for elimination were left
vague in these strange rich man's speech
he still didn't feel that it would be
wise to put himself in a compromised
position while aboard the Fateful Emma
bracing himself for the worst agent
Chang accepted the challenge of a nearby
passenger he was off to a promising
start when he threw a scissors hand
against his opponent's paper because the
matches were best two out of three all
he needed was to win one of the next two
matches and he'd survive this round then
he saw the devious look on his
opponent's face and he knew that this
match was about to get weird rather than
admit defeat agent Zhang prepared to
throw scissors again the two challenged
their hands and just as Zhang had feared
his opponent threw an anomalous gesture
almost instantly the opponent's hand
took on a multi-mouthed piscene form
which began to spit sharp teeth in agent
Zhang's Direction fortunately the
agent's bulletproof vest was able to
withstand the impact of the teeth what
was even more fortunate was the fact
that the opponent seemed to be a good
sport scissors beats as revok U.N said
the other passenger before walking away
in search of their next match curiously
the passengers transformed arm continued
to fire teeth across the room at random
intervals occasionally hitting and
causing injury to one of the other
competitors agent Zhang was grateful
that the body armor he was wearing had
been tested to withstand rapid fire from
scp-127 compared to the raw power of the
living gun the teeth launched from
azerovoc gestures were practically DB
rounds he had succeeded in not being
eliminated both from the game and
generally it excited about his win Zhang
sought out another opponent to test his
lock below deck agent DuBois and the
rest of the mobile task force had just
finished facing off against some of the
hired mercenaries when they entered a
room presumed to be the ocean liners
sickbay inside was a grisly sight a
second rock paper scissors tournament
playing out between players that had
been so thoroughly transformed by the
anomalous gestures of
scp-4633 that they barely appeared to
still be human it was like a scene from
a deep sea documentary with strange and
unknowable creatures vying for dominance
not within a natural food chain or
competition for resources but within a
seemingly never-ending struggle to win a
game of chance it was Purgatory rock
paper scissors Purgatory agent DuBois
was appalled but he knew better than to
attempt to stop these creatures from
doing the one thing keeping them all
distracted the moray-handed man was
still somewhere in the ship and
capturing him was far more important the
research team would decide what to do
with these former humans once the ship
was Secure within the foundation's
custody however what agent Dubois didn't
realize is that some of these creatures
were advancing on his team in
nightmarish and on Earthly voices they
chanted rock rock
paper scissors suddenly one of the
Abominations resembled nothing more
closely than an enormous mass of coral
produce Four Arms from within its body
and began to throw anomalous hand signs
towards the agents one of the arms threw
akyag which coded an unsuspecting agent
in hot lava causing him to drop to the
floor in pain Panic Dubois ordered the
task force to eliminate every living
thing in the sickbay although not in the
sense of their tournament standing of
course meanwhile ajin Zhang was on a win
streak in the function hall through
Sherlock and determination he had
managed to avoid elimination while
eliminating several other passengers
himself he began to notice that those
who were eliminated were quietly
escorted Away by the bouncers seeming to
have their anomalous changes treated now
it was only down to 12 remaining
passengers agent Zhang knew that it was
only a matter of time before DuBois and
his team took control of the ship but
feeling Reckless he challenged one of
the remaining passengers in that moment
something came over him as if his
determination to see the mission through
was also compelling him to win at any
cost his opponent threw pagakmar and out
of instinct Zhang threw vanyanjak the
agent went on to win the entire
tournament but sadly he was unable to
collect the prize money as during the
Skirmish below deck the man with the
Moray hand had escaped with a small
fortune in a high-speed submersible his
ultimate goals and the scope of the
shadowy group he represented would
remain unanswered for the time being
when the SS fateful Emma finally arrived
at site 45 ajin Zhang came to his senses
and realized that he had underestimated
the cognitive side effects of
scp-4633 due to the immediately
recognized possible anomalous state of
both his arms agent Zhang was later
contained on site with minimal security
it's believed that researchers are still
searching for a method to reverse the
effects it just goes to show that
winning isn't everything ask anyone that
has been through it and they'll all tell
you the same but moving home is maybe
one of the most stressful things that a
normal person can ever experience it's a
logistical nightmare right from the
start the moment you talk to a realtor
about being interested in selling your
current house and buying another
everything goes downhill from there
after that moment an avalanche of things
comes hurtling towards you finding a
place you like making an offer letting
people look around your house waiting
for them to make a counteroffer
exchanging contracts and that's before
you even have thought about packing and
as Milo had learned doing all of that on
your own only makes the stress of moving
feel all the more potent but he had
finally made it after a constant back
and forth with his realtor the time had
come for him to pack up all of his
worldly possessions and relocate to a
brand new place to call home he had felt
it was long overdue for him to get a
change of scenery and luckily just the
right place had come onto the market to
answer that call it was a pretty big
house bigger than Milo's previous home
but considerably cheaper in fact he
thought it had been significantly
undervalued the house had an almost
Victorian era feel to it all beautifully
carved and varnished Woodwork and creaky
old floorboards but in more of an
elegant refined sort of way rather than
a creepier one that's not to say Milo's
new place wasn't without its more
unsettling elements aside from being big
spacious and easy to imagine as being
haunted the creepiest thing about the
house aside from its frighteningly low
price was the story of what happened to
the previous owners obviously you know
that legally we have to disclose whether
or not anyone died on this property the
realtor had explained wearing a Force
grin as she showed Milo around the house
hearing that sentence he could feel the
hairs on the back of his neck stand up
someone died here he asked in disbelief
no no no no of course not sir the
realtor instantly walked back her
statement Less in an effort to ease her
clients nerves but more to ensure that
she still closed the deal and earned her
commission bonus and why the hell would
you start a sentence like that Milo
asked we just have to give full
disclosure but I assure you the previous
residents didn't die on the grounds of
this house she gave that fake smile
again it was pretty ineffectual at
reassuring him so what happened to the
last owner well it's a bit of a mystery
to be honest a local Legend if you like
but hey that gives the place more flavor
hearing some spooky history right think
of what a conversation starter that will
be the realtor ended her sentence with a
forced snorting laugh but rained it back
in when she realized Milo wasn't
laughing with her ah as far as I know
there used to be an older couple living
here the Jaws they were apparently very
quiet reclusive kept to themselves a lot
I'm sure you know the type Milo couldn't
help but notice she shot him a look as
she said that part as if she was
silently passing judgment on the fact he
was planning on moving in alone but they
used to spend a lot of time tending the
garden out front so their neighbors
would see them pretty frequently which
meant they were all okay and no one had
any bad mishaps in the house you know
how old folks can be such a worry when
they get to that age yeah totally Milo
interjected where the realtor was
stalling he repeated so what actually
happened to them well that's the thing
she Shrugged Nobody Knows the full story
one day the neighbors across the street
noticed they hadn't seen Mr and Mrs Shaw
for quite a while so naturally they came
on over here to see if they were in and
the last thing they wanted was to assume
everything was hunky-dory here I mean
hey better save them sorry right but
once they got inside they couldn't find
either of them Mr and Mrs Shaw were just
gone vanished Without a Trace most
people on the street thought they had
just sold the place kept it quiet and
moved away retired to somewhere nice and
exotic Oh well that sounds nice I
suppose Milo replied relieved to hear
that there hadn't been any brutal
unsolved murders in the house and that
it most likely wasn't haunted that's
just what the neighbors think anyway the
realtor continued of course they hadn't
sold the house they just left it when my
firm came in to repossess the place it
had all their belongings in it some
might even still be laying around here
anyway did you want to have a look at
that contract well strictly speaking
Milo was the only human living in his
new house he was never fully alone he
had arrived with his two closest friends
a pair of pets he had adopted while
living in his old house one was a
hamster by the name of donut named after
his round little body and the golden
brown shade of his fur had reminded Milo
of the glazed sugary baked treat the
other was Pixel a bearded dragon with a
pattern on his scales that resembled
some kind of mosaic art the first order
of business Milo had decided was before
even unpacking he needed to make sure
his scaly and furry friends each had a
suitable place to stay and that he got
them fed little did he realize there was
something else living in the house with
them something that was Far bigger and
was getting much hungrier than either of
his pets would looking around the house
Milo stumbled across a few boxes that he
hadn't brought with him like the realtor
had said the Shah still had some of
their possessions left lying around the
place most of it was useless to Milo old
man's clothes are a set of knitting
needles and rolls of colorful thread it
was those particular clues that seemed
to imply Mrs Shaw had a lot of free time
on her hands and maybe took up knitting
as a hobby during retirement of course
the bigger clue was the huge handmade
blanket that Milo found draped over some
of the remaining boxes in the Attic he
wasn't exactly well versed in knitwear
but he could appreciate the craft behind
this soft blanket it clearly had a lot
of time and effort put into making it
painstakingly knitting each and every
individual thread looping it around a
pair of Steel needles and eventually
after hours of wearing out shaking bony
fingers produce something that actually
looked quite nice even though the idea
of sitting and knitting a blanket might
have been one of the most boring uses of
time Milo could imagine he still had to
admit he was surprised that the Shaws
had left this particular piece of
bedding behind it seemed like it would
be pretty comfy to sleep under it might
help keep a person warm at night now
that the colder seasons were approaching
what's more was that the blanket was
clean almost like it had been freshly
washed there was no old person smell on
it no dirt or discoloration not a stain
and it hadn't even accumulated any dust
in its fibers in fact he noticed that
there was hardly any dust at all up in
the attic despite the house being empty
for so long he assumed the Realtors had
hired someone As a caretaker while they
found a buyer for the place and they had
kept the place clean after all what
other conclusion could they have
possibly drawn it's not as if something
had eaten all the dust that would be
absurd he'd have a sort through of the
Shaw's leftovers later maybe sell some
of it off at a local yard sale or give
it to a thrift store but that blanket
might come in handy when it started
snowing so Milo had half a mind to keep
it now part of what makes moving home
such a stressful life experience isn't
just all the logistical and
administrative parts of the process it's
only made worse by the fact that it
takes forever to move into a new house
fully that's the part everyone always
forgets about the months after a move
when you're forced to live amongst
towers of cardboard boxes all your
worldly possessions buried deep within
them and you can never remember which
crate anything is in when you urgently
need it so realizing it would take him
much longer to unpack all this thing
things Milo set about making sure he had
everything that donut and pixel would
need already to hand the latter of his
two Pets the bearded dragon usually
spent most of his days in a spacious
glass tank Milo didn't love the idea of
keeping either of his two best buds so
confined but pixel never went very far
anyway content to lay under a heat lamp
almost perfectly still for most of the
day donut on the other hand was much
more of a free spirit the tiny brown
hamster physically could not stay still
and most days seem to be filled with
more energy than Milo was as a result he
let the little guy roll about inside a
little plastic ball all day long until
his little hamster feet gave out and now
donut had much more space to zip around
inside his ball so while he entertained
himself Milo could focus on what needed
fixing cleaning and generally improving
around the house it didn't take him long
to realize however that the Realtors had
pulled a bit of a fast one on him
despite the absolute steal of a price
that Milo had been offered it quickly
became clear that the unknown fate of
the previous residents wasn't the only
detail about the house that had been
conveniently kept hidden the place was
in dire need of repair with a lot of the
old woodwork rapidly rotting away if
left unchecked parts of the house could
collapse and come apart at the seams to
make matters worse the boiler was an
ancient iron monstrosity that was barely
able to produce warm water which would
quickly become an even bigger problem
when the weather started to get colder
then to top off the trifecta of
unforeseen issues and teething problems
with his new place Milo couldn't sleep
it was to be expected after all the
house was old worn out and had
definitely seen better days there were
bound to be a few noises the odd Creek
coming from upstairs when Milo and his
two pets were all downstairs the tapping
of branches against Windows blowing in
the wind outside but for some reason
every audible disturbance had emanated
from some hidden corner of the building
only seemed to get a thousand times
louder when the sun went down at night
time every squeaky floorboard or random
noise of the house settling was nearly
deafening enough to pull Milo right out
of what little Restless sleep he was
getting the worst part about it was
though he couldn't help it it made him
feel unwelcome as if Mr and Mrs Shaw
were angered that he had moved in in the
dark it was hard not to picture every
sound as one or both of the old couple
creeping through the corridors coming to
reclaim their home and remove Milo from
the premises one night the noises
started invading what little sleep Milo
did manage to get spilling into his
dream and causing them to devolve into
unsettling nightmares there was an old
photograph in a frame that he had come
across in the personal effects left
behind by the Shahs showing the pair of
them staring disapprovingly out of the
image at him now thanks to the creaking
wooden structure of the house and the
sounds it made at night Milo is seeing
the old couple in every bad dream he had
both their face were locked in those
same still frozen expressions of
contempt as they try to exercise him
like an interloper on their property
that was the final nail in the coffin
that made Milo realize he needed to look
at other options surely there had to be
some way to induce a deep enough sleep
so that the sounds the house was making
weren't keeping him up or incepting
nightmares anymore he called the local
doctor arranging a consultation for
later that day as he hung up the phone
something nudged against his foot it was
donut having rolled through the Maze of
cardboard boxes still filling the house
Milo took one look at the little brown
furred hamster than the crates that
still littered the place grabbing the
leftover items that the Shahs had
forgotten to take with them before they
vanished Milo moved those boxes out into
the shed he knew he was probably
reaching that it was hard likely to make
even the slightest difference to his
sleeping but maybe keeping their stuff
away from him would keep the old couple
out of his head the only thing he kept
in the house was the blanket there was
no use letting it go to waste especially
knowing that the boiler was on the blink
and it would be cold soon he rolled it
up and left it on his bed leaving his
more mobile pet in the same room before
heading out to see the doctor when Milo
got back a bottle of prescription
sleeping pills in his pocket he couldn't
help but notice his room seemed
different the blanket looked like it had
fallen off the bed and onto the floor
for one but more worryingly Donuts
plastic travel ball had been split open
laying in pieces on the ground with its
furry little occupant nowhere to be seen
over the next few hours Milo searched
every corner of the house calling out to
his hamster trying to lure it back with
more morsels of food but donut didn't
seem to be anywhere he wasn't even
underneath the knitted blanket still
there was no sign as worry set in Milo
Hurley checked pixels cage to see if he
was gone too but the lizard was relaxing
as lethargic as ever completely unfazed
by what was going on it certainly seemed
that when it rained it really poured in
this new house just as he was searching
for his missing hamster Milo heard a new
horrible sound echo through the
corridors this one wasn't so much a
scary noise even if it did make him jump
but it was more the inconvenience that
came with it finally giving out after
God knows how many years it had been
installed for the house is boiler burst
spending the afternoon into the evening
failing to track down one of his Missing
Pets and stopping the huge iron cast
boiler from flooding the basement wasn't
exactly what Milo had in mind for fun
activities to do when he got home going
to bed frustrated made it as hard to
sleep as all the nightly cacophony of
creaking floorboards and branches raking
against the windows he tapped out two of
the pills the doctor had prescribed him
knocking them back with a sharp motion
of his head and a swig of cold water
before laying back in bed as night had
fallen the temperature also had
plummeted too not having a boiler to
heat his room meant that Milo couldn't
stop himself from shivering in the cold
his breath forming clouds in front of
his face he reached for the knitted
blanket and threw it over himself
curling up underneath it to try and
provide an extra layer of warmth to
protect himself from the gnawing cold
the pills did as they were meant to
helping Milo to quickly sleep into a
much deeper sleep than he had
experienced in a while although it
didn't seem to help the nightmares Mr
and Mrs Shaw came back again this time
they had Milo's arms and legs tied up
with their matching disapproving faces
the elderly couple threw something over
their helpless victim and tried to
smother him to death for a dream it felt
so intense so real Milo could feel a
heavy weight on top of his body as he
slept in fact it felt like it was all
around him engulfing and crushing the
life out of him from all sides but it
was the feeling of something wet against
his arm the sensation of liquid against
his skin and the numbness where his
hands should be were what finally pulled
him out of the dream and into the
nightmare through the dark and his
cloudy vision Milo could see a wide
gaping moth filled with teeth the
feeling of being crushed was still
surrounding him and despite kicking his
legs and trying to free himself from
confinement it didn't stop squeezing him
tighter his Panic was already making it
harder to catch his breath but now he
could barely fill his lungs enough to
scream for help not that anyone was
around to hear him but it was the sight
of his arm that chilled Milo's blood it
wasn't there anymore part of it just
above the elbow was just gone his hand
fingers every internal bone and muscle
had been reduced to a bloody mess a
slurry of red melting and coming apart
it was runny little more than a liquid
resembling the consistency of sand when
it's underwater and becomes sludge most
of his flesh was liquefied going further
up his arm and as the blanket pulled its
prey into its mouth until Milo was no
more not a trace of him left just like
the previous owner little did Milo or
the Shaws and donut before him know but
he'd been the victim of a creature that
was part of a rather unique species
while they will often vary in size shape
pattern and other aspects of their
appearance
scp-799 always seemed to be ordinary
items of knitted bedware at least at
first they retain heat like a normal
blanket would and are soft to the touch
and for the most part don't seem
directly harmful and usually they aren't
scp-799s are incapable of much movement
instead laying still a lot of time not
unlike a certain bearded dragon that
just lost its owner they also don't seem
to require much in the way of food
extracting with little nutrition they do
need by drawing in household dust a lot
of the organic matter and dust is
comprised of dead and discarded human
hair and skin cells so this makes sense
this feeding is all done through
filtered mouths in the fibers however
this changes if an scp-799 blanket is
forced to go on a long time without food
well they possess this biological trait
themselves
scp-799 don't seem to regard
cold-blooded animals to be the source of
food in fact they don't even seem to be
able to detect other creatures with cold
blood such as reptiles instead scp-799
will metamorphose into a more predatory
form in order to consume any
warm-blooded mammal or human being it
encounters transforming its feeding
orifices and digestive tract into a
singular mouth lined with several rolls
of sharp pointed teeth from there it
will wrap up the largest warm-blooded
animal it can find whether that be a
hamster or a grown man and will tear off
parts of its prey reducing them to
little more than a thin slurry as it
digests their body mass to feed itself
so if you move into a new house and come
across an old knitted blanket maybe
consider throwing it out if you want to
live welcome back dear viewers of SCP
explain we hope you've been keeping well
and we also hope that your health
insurance covers blown Minds because
today we're using our trademark
anomatron 6000 to pit an anomalous
Legend against another Marvel Legend
that's right it's scp-682 versus Dr
Michael morbius of the 2022 cinematic
Masterpiece morbius of course there is
one issue that we should share with you
before we begin we haven't actually seen
morbius however here's the wonderful
thing statistically you haven't either
in fact we tried to get the animatron
6000 to process morbius as raw data for
the simulation but our antivirus
software kept stopping it intriguing so
instead we simply hit randomized traits
on the animatron so it's free to use
Advanced AI could conceive what morbius
is like and what his abilities probably
are and as far as you or I know it might
even be correct so let's get this show
on the road and see if the hard to
destroy reptile could hone against its
own at Cinema's most tragically memed
upon superhero prepare for perhaps the
most absurd and ridiculous video with
the exception of the Among Us video that
we've ever released on here in other
words it's morbin time it began as many
bizarre SCP Foundation stories do with
scp-682 cracking the glass of its acid
tank and preparing to spill chaos and
Terror onto site 19. for most people
even seeing actual footage of this would
be a life-defining traumatic incident
for most seasoned Foundation researchers
it was just another Sunday when 682
busted through the nearest wall like a
psychopathic reptilian Kool-Aid man
while guards engaged in the futile task
of trying to subdue it with small arms
fire the senior researchers languidly
made their way to the nearest secure
Panic Room and hunkered down as was
standard protocol for scp-682 escapes
all available mobile task force units
would be dispatched single-mindedly
focused on cutting the lizard back down
to size but the problem was this wasn't
just any other Sunday it was Super Bowl
Sunday and seeing as most mobile task
force operatives are incredibly tough
and manly they generally love football
and promise they definitely come and
take down 682 as soon as the game was
over this would be one thing if scp-682
was content to just terrorize the usual
denizens of Psych 19 today but no it'd
been a while since the hard to destroy
reptile had tasted civilian flesh and he
intended to rectify that toot sweet in a
state of murderous Fury 682 barged
through wall after wall with the effort
that a normal human might walk through
rice paper soon enough it was free from
the drive gray walls of the containment
site and feeling the sun on its scales
once more such a lovely day out with the
distant sound of people laughing and
chatting and children playing happily
with their pets 682 predictably found
this disgusting and resolved to destroy
them all and with all those mobile tasks
for course operative swigging beer
eating peanuts and giggling at amusing
celebrity cameos in Super Bowl Halftime
ads there would be nobody who would stop
682 from completing it's dastardly task
except of course one man Dr Michael
morbius while 682 was escaping morbius
was sitting on the deck of his private
yacht drinking a martini glass full of
two percent milk because morbius
understands the importance of having
healthy bones he was listening to a
fantastic podcast about the Curative
powers of beef jerky when high above the
SCP Foundation activated the morb signal
a batman-esque light shining up in the
sky in the shape of a clown this was bad
morbius paused his podcast and prepared
himself finishing the last of his milk
and washing out the glass so it didn't
get smelly he raised his arm and
summoned the morb orb a glowing red ball
that seemed to be the source of his
powers according to a number of internet
memes he clutched the orb feeling its
power flow through him as he made a
small prayer to his Guardian deity the
late David Bowie and with that he took
flight twin Jets of fire blasting out of
his shoes like rocket ships he could
only hope that he'd be able to intercept
as cp-682 before it was too late
meanwhile scp-682 was indulging in one
of his favorite hobbies just killing
lots of people he'd invaded the American
city of San Fran angliss New York which
was known for being the biggest
population of people within the
proximity of Psych 19. 682 was truly
rampaging he knocked the ice cream cones
out of children's hands causing them to
weep profusely he literally kicked dogs
and he also murdered a number of adults
with his vicious fangs and Claws the
local police attempted to stop him but
they were hopelessly outmatched they
attempted to Cuff the monster several
times only to find out that by the time
they were halfway through trying to read
the Beast it's Miranda rights he would
break free and Rampage yet again all in
all 682 was having a grand old time and
was delighted that nobody was coming to
stop its Rampage of utter Devastation it
seemed almost as though the Rampage
would never end until a dark shadow fell
over the ravenous reptilian monster it
turned up its head to see a new foe
floating above it was it a bird was it a
plane no it was Dr Michael morbius of
course wielding his trademark flaming
Trident of Justice another lamb to the
slaughter 682 growled are you ready to
meet your end Morpheus laughed and shook
his head I don't know who you are you
scaly monster but for hurting all these
innocent people you're about to get
morbid on and with that he threw his
flaming Trident at the reptile striking
Brave and true but it wasn't enough 682
had developed incredibly strong reflexes
after years of the foundation's attempts
on its life so morbius would need to try
a lot harder than just using his classic
beloved Trident to end this fight even
then before more obvious had a chance to
think up another method of attack 682
had adapted and switched to the offense
two great dragon-like leathery Wings
unfurled on the monster's back and it
took to the air lunging towards morbius
with fangs born in claws at the ready
before morbius knew it the creature's
Jaws were ready to close around his head
thankfully at this moment another one of
morbius's classic superpowers comes into
play his short-range teleportation
abilities in a moment of reflex that
would impress 682 morbius teleported out
of the monster's path remanifesting
instantly floating a few feet away 682
growled in irritation of course it would
never be so easy it said the foundation
always sends one of its freaks to
distract me you may think you're strong
but really you're just another puppet
I've never heard of this Foundation
morbius quipped back and I'm not your
standard hero either I really blur the
line between hero and villain entirely
in fact before morbius could finish
explaining what a complex character he
was if you could even use that word 682
flew after him again this time however
morbius was ready he lifted up his arms
and Unleashed another one of his
patented attacks opening up human mouths
in the palms of his hands which
Unleashed miniature yet still extremely
powerful air-to-air missiles the
missiles blasted out and struck 682
causing an impressive explosion but 682
was well versed in explosions it kept
flying after morbius he needed to get
out of here fast or he'd become a
lizard's lunch morbius turned and flew
in the opposite direction the hard to
destroy reptile hot on his heels the
first step of course would be to get
away from populated areas to limit
collateral damage no matter what
happened morbius refused to let this
mysterious entity harm more people you
cannot run forever 682 ground your
wretched life will be brought to a slow
and painful end stranger they were
passing over the water now flying at
Quantum speeds watching the Pacific
Ocean whiz past beneath them that's when
morbius noticed it and had an epiphany a
volcano and by the looks of the smoke
Rising above it an active one too
morbius had a plan now but to execute it
he'd need perfect speed and timing he
stopped in mid-air as the Beast flew
towards him but moments before 682 could
make contact morvis grabbed it executing
a perfect mid-air suplex and tossed the
Roaring Beast directly down into the
volcano below for any other monster this
would be the end of it but for 682 a
double triple or even quadruple tap was
often required to reliably incapacitated
morbius's work was not done he flew down
towards the volcano ready to engage in
the next hectic stage of battle bet
you're not feeling so cocky now you
nasty reptile Morpheus yelled but the
reptile in question was too busy
flailing around in possibly hot magma to
reply at the time such is the way when
falling into an active volcano
scp-682 burnt in chart but still alive
began to crawl from the top of the
volcano wheezing out smoke and Ash how
could such a strange confusing creature
have been such a formidable opponent no
matter it will destroy this Morpheus it
might just take a little longer than
expected little did the unfortunate
reptile know morbius Was preparing his
next weapon perfect for immobilizing
this ornery monster an eight ball in a
gym sock forming a kind of dangerous
makeshift flail it was the kind of
lethal improvised weapon that would
strike fear into even the strongest of
enemy combatants and now scp-682 would
learn to fear its power as the flame
broiled reptile began to stand perhaps
preparing to adapt to its latest set of
injuries morbius began relentlessly
beating the hard to destroy reptile with
the eight ball sock dazing it with
repeated brutal strikes that never
seemed to stop morbius had learned this
technique from years of being involved
in vicious bar fights normally caused by
him cheating at darts this can stop any
time you want Morpheus yelled you just
need to stop getting back up initially
682 wanted to remain defiant but even it
could not deny that being struck again
and again by the eight ball sock was
actually extremely painful was it really
worth the fight after performing some
quick mental calculations
scp-682 determined that no it probably
wasn't time to throw in the towel okay
okay 682 said mostly just annoyed at
this point I'll stop rampaging honestly
you just took all the fun out of it 682
just sighed and laid on the ground
exhausted slowly regenerating from its
injuries morbius smiled content with his
victory who knows how many people he'd
saved by luring this creature away from
a population Center by this point this
Super Bowl was over and the legions of
mobile task force operatives who
technically should have done this hours
ago finally decided to suit up and take
care of business it didn't take long for
Black Tactical helicopters full of
foundation soldiers to triangulate the
location of the volcano where the end of
682 and morbius's epic battle had taken
place it wasn't long after that that
there were copious Foundation boots on
the ground this story of course has a
happy ending mobile task force agents
successfully recaptured scp-682 and
returned it to its containment cell in
site-19 and in the process of recovery
they mistook Dr Michael morbius for the
actor Jared Leto and shot him roughly 30
times in the chest with armor-piercing
rounds killing him instantly want an
anomaly of your own check out
www.scpswag.com for high quality SCP
merch now go and check out scp-096
versus siren head and scp-076 able vs
chainsaw man who has the most lethal
weapon for more Wild versus battles